so und damit kommen wir zur schlussrunde
zum haushaltsgesetz hier wird dann noch
mal ein rundumschlag gemacht werden
können und wir sehen das auch schon an
der regierungsbank dort haben sich schon
einige minister eingefunden um hier der
debatte noch mal zu folgen auch
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
ist schon da auch er hat sich hier
angekündigt wird hier noch mal sprechen
zum haushalt 400
57,6 milliarden euro soll der haushalt
2022 insgesamt betragen und gleichzeitig
möchte christian lindner an seinen
zielen festhalten keine steuererhöhungen
neuverschuldung im kernhaushalt sollen
nicht höher als knapp 100 milliarden
euro sein und die schuldenbremse soll ab
20 23 wieder eingehalten werden
ein parteikollege von christian lindner
wird hier auch die rede beginnen die
debatte otto fricke
kollegen schlussrunde heißt resümee
dieser woche zu ziehen und dabei filmen
fallen mir zwei dinge auch diese
koalition hat es geschafft innerhalb des
halben jahres sich schlagkräftig zu
formieren und beim haushalt dafür zu
sorgen die realitäten anzuerkennen und
gleichzeitig auf das was an neuen dingen
auf uns zukommt auch zu reagieren das
ist etwas was man dieser koalition nicht
zugetraut hat aber ich bin stolz darauf
dass wir das bis hierhin geschafft haben
auch wenn jetzt die arbeit im ausschuss
bin ich
und wenn ich dann
auf die einzig eigentlich ernst zu
nehmende opposition schaue und
gleichzeitig auf diese schöne
sonnenwetter draußen schaue dann fällt
mir nur herwig mitteregger 1985 mit dem
lied immer mehr immer mehr immer mehr
ein wenn ich nämlich sehe was hier
passiert ist dann muss ich wirklich
sagen wir wollen den parlamentarischen
diskurs doch die diskussion mit ihnen
über ihre inhalte über ihre ideen um
unsere wie wir meinen besseren ideen mit
ihrem zu messen und dann zu einer
entscheidung zu kommen und dazu müsste
von ihnen etwas kommen dann habe ich
mein büro mal gebeten in jeder rede zu
gucken wo denn bei ihnen mehr gefordert
habe gedacht ich kriege und din a4 blatt
ich kann ihnen mal zeigen was ich hier
alles von ihm da zu lesen hat und das
war nur das war nur dass bis zum
donnerstag und wollte auch in den
letzten beiden dekaden arbeit und
soziales und familie ja man kann immer
sagen immer mehr immer mehr immer mehr
aber wir müssen doch erkennen wie wir
uns jetzt auf das konzentrieren was in
einer sozialen marktwirtschaft dann auch
wirklich notwendig ist und da kann man
nicht noch mal kommen in debatten und
sagen wir machen jetzt neue
sozialleistung zusätzliche
sozialleistungen ohne zu überlegen wie
wir sie im system anpassen oder aber was
sie auch noch machen wir fordern die
verlängerung von subventionen oder
neueinführung von subventionen oder man
macht so verleger dinge wie sie heute in
der familien debatte sagen man sagt ja
dass mit der ukraine flüchtlingen da
finde ich nix im haushalt ja natürlich
finde ich nichts im haushalt das ist
doch klar das wird doch durch den
ergänzungs haushalt erfolgen und
deswegen ist meine bitte und deswegen
ist meine bitte an
definieren sie noch mal was die diese
woche gemacht haben wo am anfang dann
ein herr merz erzählt ja sie machen ja
nichts was ja katastrophal war im
haushalt danach sagen dann alle nehmen
wir müssen noch mehr ausgeben das
problem bei indes doch wenn es nach ihm
ginge da gibt es nicht nur den
notwendigen ergänzungs haushalt wegen
der ukraine krise sondern gebe es nach
ihrem wunsch noch einen zweiten
ergänzungs cdu haushalt und das werden
wir mit sicherheit nicht macht und dann
noch ein anderes und dann noch ein
anderes ob das würde ich schon sagen wir
wollen den diskurs mit in dem ringen um
das bessere das ist doch das was
demokratie ausmacht aber ich habe dann
mal den test gemacht so wenn bei ihm im
facebook so froh ist er gesagt und was
schlecht ist und dann habe ich immer mal
drüber geschrieben ja was sind denn ihre
vorschläge wissen sie was passt bei
allen kunden die antwort ist ja die muss
die regierung vorlegen nein jetzt sind
wir in parlamenten im haushalt es ist
ihre aufgabe sie müssen das tun das ist
die einzige welt und weil mich der
justizminister unbeweglich frei nach
haben jetzt weiter als zweite szene es
ist zwar wahnsinn doch ihre methode
gefällt mir nicht herzlichen dank
der haushaltspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
hier sehr deutlich
mit seiner kritik an den reben die
opposition auf ihn folgt nun jannik
burri er ist obmann im unterausschuss zu
fragen der europäischen union das ist
ein unterausschuss des
haushaltsausschusses
der sich also mit europa vorlagen
beschäftigt und das ist seine erste rede
im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir sind am ende der
haushaltswoche wir haben diese woche
intensiv diskutiert über den
haushaltsentwurf über die
finanzplanungen ja auch über die rekord
schulden die sie als bundesregierung
planen es sind technische zahlen
basierte debatten das gehört sich so als
haushälter und das ist ja auch richtig
so in einer haushaltswoche gestatten sie
mir aber dass ich zum ende dieser
haushaltswoche unsere debatte um eine
ganz persönliche perspektive ergänzen
möchte vor 17 tagen bin ich zum ersten
mal vater geworden und nicht nur ich
sondern an dem tag zusammen mit an dem
tag zusammen mit etwa 2000 weiteren
müttern und vätern in unserem land und
wenn man in diesen tagen eine familie
gründet während wir alle die bilder der
flüchtenden familien aus der ukraine
sehen dann bekommt das was wir diese
woche hier diskutiert haben dann kommt
das wort zeitenwende und dann bekommt
natürlich auch dieser haushalt und die
finanzplanung was ja beides die
grundlage der politik nicht nur in
diesem jahr sondern auch in den
kommenden jahren sein werden eine andere
bedeutung es ist eine andere bedeutung
aus zwei gründen erstens weil wir heute
vor allem anderen auf die frage eine
antwort geben müssen und wie wir
freiheit und sicherheit in europa
dauerhaft sichern und zwar nicht nur für
unsere generation nicht nur in den
nächsten vier jahren sondern für unsere
kinder und für kommende generationen
und zweitens weil wir gleichzeitig vor
der herausforderung stehen das zu tun
ohne dabei heute so viele schulden
aufzutürmen dass wir der nächsten
generation schon jetzt alle
handlungsmöglichkeiten nehmen um auf
kommende herausforderungen überhaupt
noch reagieren zu können und diese
beiden kriterien zusammen zu bringen auf
der einen seite freiheit und sicherheit
dauerhaft zu sichern und auf der anderen
seite finanzielle handlungsmöglichkeiten
für kommende generationen offen zu
halten das ist es was
generationengerechte haushaltspolitik in
diesen tagen definiert denn wir stehen
in der verantwortung nicht nur für die
nächsten vier jahre sondern für kommende
generationen und herr minister lindner
auf diese herausforderung geben ihr
haushaltsentwurf in ihre finanzplanung
darauf diesen spagat zusammenzubringen
bisher noch keine überzeugende antwort
diese verantwortung übernehmen sie
bisher noch nicht und das ist der punkt
das ist auch der grund warum wir
bedingungen stellen die für uns erfüllt
sein müssen damit wir beispielsweise dem
sondervermögen bundeswehr zustimmen das
tun wir nicht als selbstzweck diese
bedingungen aufzustellen sondern das tun
wir um sicherzustellen dass dieses geld
wirklich da ankommt wo unsere freiheit
verteidigt wird nämlich bei der
bundeswehr und zwar nicht nur in den
nächsten vier jahren sondern dauerhaft
denn es geht nicht nur um unsere
freiheit heute es geht auch um freiheit
und sicherheit für die nächste
generation
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
ist auch der grund warum wir von ihnen
einfordern dass sie im haus halten der
finanzplanung prioritätensetzungen zwei
die richtigen prioritäten setzen anstatt
ihre politik der nächsten jahre
maßgeblich über schulden und über
sondervermögen zu finanzieren
und auch diese forderung ist kein
selbstzweck denn mit den schulden die
sie in diesem jahr planen werden alleine
durch die damit verbundenen
tilgungsverpflichtungen die spielräume
der schuldenbremse für die nächsten 30
jahre quasi komplett aufgebraucht dass
sie kurzfristig nicht richtig
priorisieren wollen führt mittelfristig
dazu dass beispielsweise für die
stabilisierung der sozialsysteme ab
20.25 so gut wie kein finanzieller
spielraum mehr bleibt das ist eine
finanzpolitik die mehr bis zum ende der
wahlperiode denkt als an kommende
generationen das ist eine finanzpolitik
die den kommenden generationen
finanzielle handlungsmöglichkeiten nimmt
und darum will ich hier auch entschieden
widersprechen wenn in den letzten tagen
an dieser stelle oft gesagt wurde ein
solider haushalt zeit kein wert an sich
doch liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ein
solider haushalt ist ein wert an sich
weil ein solider haushalt heute darüber
entscheidet ob die nächste generation
für neue herausforderungen überhaupt
noch handlungsmöglichkeiten haben wird
und ein solider haushalt deutschlands
ist ein wert an sich weil er
entscheidend ist für die stabilität in
europa und nichts brauchen wir in diesen
tagen mehr als ein stabiles europa für
unsere generation heute aber vor allem
um der nächsten generation um unseren
kindern ein stabiles europa zu
hinterlassen und darum meine damen und
herren freue ich mich auf die nun
anstehenden haushaltsberatungen im
ausschuss wir werden uns dafür einsetzen
und herr minister ihnen da auch den
druck machen dass aus diesem entwurf
doch noch eine solidere haushaltspolitik
wird die nicht nur vordergründig sondern
auch tatsächlich freiheit und sicherheit
absichert und gleichzeitig
handlungsmöglichkeiten für die zukunft
lässt und zwar nicht nur für heute
sondern auch für die nächste generation
für meinen sohn aber auch für jedes
andere kind das in diesen tagen zur welt
kommt und dass wir auch mit diesem
haushalt verantwortung trage den
aktuellen tagen vermutlich mehr denn je
vielen dank
das war also die erste
der nächste redner ist auch noch relativ
neu im bundestag allerdings politisch
gesehen doch schon ein relativ alter
hase auf dem politischen parkett kevin
kühnert spricht jetzt für die
sozialdemokraten er ist im bundestag
mitglied im ausschuss für
stadtentwicklung bauwesen und kommunen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren herr kollege ich will
mir dann doch gerne mal diese beiden
schwerpunkte vornehmen die sie gerade
namens ihrer fraktionen hier dargestellt
haben möchte mal überprüfen ob sie dem
eigentlich in dieser haushaltswoche und
drumherum gerecht geworden sind ich habe
jetzt verstanden es geht also einerseits
um solidität in der haushaltspolitik
nicht zu viele schulden machen an die
nächsten generationen
denken ich krieg das nicht ganz überein
mit der zustimmung dazu dass sie uns ja
ausdrücklich darin unterstützen das
sondervermögen über 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr auf den weg zu
bringen sie haben uns neben der sehr
langen liste von kollegen fricke die
reben hier beeindruckend gezeigt hat
unter anderem auch abverlangen um 25
milliarden zusätzlich alleine im
einzelplan 14 bei der truppe zusätzlich
oben drauf zu packen sie haben noch in
der alten regierung dem ersten
regierungsentwurf zum kernhaushalt
selbst mit einer nettoneuverschuldung
von 99,7 milliarden zu bestimmen wollen
jetzt nichts mehr davon wissen also
dieses versprechen allein schon halten
sie selber nicht ein was sie hier
einfordern mit dem position die sie
diese woche eingenommen da müssen sie
sich entscheiden von der zweite punkt
die sicherheit und unabhängigkeit in
schwierigen zeiten auf unserem kontinent
wo krieg in der ukraine tobt und droht
einen ganzen kontinent zu erfassen ich
kann das nicht damit über einbringen
dass ihre fraktion ja weiterhin
außerhalb irgendwas verpasst gegen den
nachtragshaushalt und damit 60
milliarden euro auch für mehr
unabhängigkeit die beispielsweise durch
die privatwirtschaft in deutschland den
energie politischer hinsicht
herzustellen ist dass sie das weiterhin
beklagen und nicht durchgesetzt sehen
wollen und wenn ihnen das so wichtig
wäre mit der sicherheit die wir ja die
wir in diesen tagen sehen im
energiepolitischen bereich in besonderer
weise herausarbeiten müssen dann wäre
ihr platz nicht vorne am pult um die
fraktion der koalition anzurufen dazu
sondern hielt platz müsste sein in
nordrhein westfalen teil freund herrn
wüst darauf hinzuweisen dass es aber mal
so was von letztes jahrhundert ist in
diesem moment wo wir über
energiepolitische unabhängigkeit
sprechen immer noch an abstandsregeln
von 1000 metern für windkraftanlagen
festzuhalten dass so ein stück aus dem
tollhaus was sie da präsentieren 1000
meter abstand sie bauen in nordrhein
westfalen nur noch ein drittel von dem
was gebaut wurde als sie die
landesregierung dort übernommen haben
oder im saarland wo die antwort des
ministerpräsidenten auf steigende
energiepreise und die angst von leuten
vor energieabhängigkeit von herrn putin
ist sich mit einem sehr viel video als
verantwortlicher vor die zapfsäule zu
stellen das ist hilflos das bringt keine
zustimmung in der bevölkerung
deswegen gehen die umfragewerte runter
deswegen wird das kein schöner
wahlsonntag deswegen machen sie alle ihr
vorsitzender irgendeine reise kräht er
diese woche keine wahlkampftermine mehr
im saarland da kann man dann zwar frei
nach harald juhnke sagen keine termine
und leicht einen sitzen damit hat man
ein schönes freies wochenende aber
keinen schönen wahlabend am sonntag
meine damen und herren kunde
unionsfraktion ist einfach an der zeit
vorbei was sie in verantwortung dortmund
verantwortung sind tatsächlich machen
was wir gemacht haben in dieser woche
und zwar für den ländlichen raum
gleichermaßen wie für die großstädte
rinnen und großstädter ist ein zweites
entlastungspaket herr kollege auf den
weg zu bringen noch mal im umfang von
gut 20 milliarden euro nach dem ersten
im umfang von gut 15 milliarden euro und
jetzt sagen sie wenn mal was von den
maßnahmen wieder auf den weg gebracht
worden was irgendwie arrogant oder
schlecht ausdifferenziert wäre
abschaffung eeg umlage der ersten sieben
sie auch immer gefordert fern
pendlerpauschale
die ersten 22 rückwirkend
heizkostenzuschuss 230 euro verwies und
für bafög empfängerinnen und empfänger
270 euro für single-haushalte 350 470
euro obendrauf für jede weitere person
im haushalt eine einmalzahlung nicht nur
die 100 euro aus dem ersten paket
sondern jetzt noch mal verdoppelt 200
euro für bedürftige aus
transferleistungen haushalten nun sofort
zuschlag von 20 euro pro monat für
kinder in armut in deutschland bis wir
die kindergrundsicherung tatsächlich auf
den weg gebracht haben grundfreibetrag
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag hoch
mindestlohn von 12 euro per ersten
zehnten in diesem jahr für millionen
menschen in deutschland verlängerung
kurzarbeitergeld in der pandemie das
vierte ko oder steuer hilfe gesetze um
auch die unternehmen sicher durch diese
pandemie und diese kriegssituation in
der ukraine mit all ihren
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
durchzubringen energie pauschale für 300
euro für alle erwerbstätigen menschen in
deutschland einmal bonus für jedes kind
von 100 euro drei monate absenkungen
energie steuer auf kraftstoffe und die
neuen euro flat für den öffentlichen
nahverkehr in deutschland zu holen jetzt
sagen sie mir bitte wäre ich hier
ausgelassen wurde westen
lebenswirklichkeit hier nicht gesehen
wurde am ende das möchte ich wirklich
mal gerne genannter das ist die
unterstützung die diese bundesregierung
bis hierhin leistet um deutschland in
dieser phase durchzubringen denn was
ihnen anscheinend immer noch nicht klar
geworden ist herr putin
hat genau vier ziele verfolgt gehabt bei
der spaltung der vorantreiben will das
eine war der spaltung versuch gegenüber
der gesellschaft innerhalb der ukraine
selbst da ist sie mit misslungen die
russischen truppen treffen nicht auf
menschen in der ukraine die befreit
werden sollen sondern die widerstand
leisten dass der erste felder sich
geleistet hat das zweite weiter versucht
hat hinzubekommen ist die europäische
union zu spalten es ist die nicht
gelungen die europäische union gerade
auch unter der koordinierung der
innenministerin die das im moment gerade
rund um die flüchtlingsaufnahme
organisiert ist nicht gespalten
bitter war der versucht die nato in das
westliche bündnis zu spalten das ist
nicht gelungen und das vierte und das
dürfen wir alle miteinander nicht
vergessen ist der versuch
sozialpolitisch diese gesellschaft
auseinander zu treiben zur besten
sendezeit wird den menschen in russland
im moment in ihrem staatsfernsehen
erzählt in deutschland gebe es auf den
straßen ausschreitungen und
großdemonstration weil hier angeblich
alles durch die decke gehen würde wir
wissen und sehen dass es nicht der fall
aber diese regierung und diese koalition
trägt eben auch dazu bei das ist dabei
bleibt meine damen und herren und das
ist ja gegenstand dessen was ich ihm
gerade noch mal vorgelesen haben und da
können sie sich mit ihren und aufregen
sondern das ist genau die entlastung die
die menschen in deutschland jetzt
brauchen und weil ich den namen schröder
eben gerade auch noch mal gehört habe an
dieser stelle jeder hat in diesen zeiten
sein päckchen zu tragen was ist in jeder
partei der fall und manche glaube ich
wenn ich vielleicht auch noch mal zu den
kollegen der linken in erwartung des
nächsten redebeiträgen gleich rüber
gucke manche sollten vielleicht in
diesen tagen auch überlegen ob es immer
noch der richtige zeitpunkt ist um hans
modrow ein kleines kabuff in der
parteizentrale bereitzuhalten von wo aus
er wirklich absurde thesen über diesen
krieg in der ukraine verbreiten können
ich halte das für unangemessen jeder hat
sein päckchen zu tragen aber ich bin bei
euch sind ein paar viele mittlerweile
geworden man könnte denken drei wochen
werden mussten sondern weihnachten und
das ist wirklich auch mit traurige
nachricht meine damen und herren ich
bedanke mich für die beratungen dieser
woche ich bedanke mich bei den
koalitionspartnern und bei den
mitgliedern in der regierung für die
harte arbeit daran dass mir die menschen
durch diese pandemie aber auch durch
diese kriegssituation hindurch begleiten
das ist die handschrift dieser ampel
koalition und ich bin stolz darauf dass
wir das nach kaum mehr als 100 tagen
dieser regierung so gut gemeinsam
hinbekommen vielen dank dafür
nun hat war das
hat auch gleich auf angriffe mit gegen
den angriff reagiert
die einschätzungen von parteigrenzen zum
fernen krieg angeht auf ihn folgen peter
böhringer der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der fdp ziehen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin über der ganzen
haushaltswoche schwebte das neue
lauterbach diktum wir werden ab jetzt
immer im ausnahmezustand sein
in nur einem haushaltsjahr wird über
zehn milliarden euro für corona tests
gegeben und sogar noch mehr für m rna
impfungen die massen infektionen in
keinerlei weise verringern derzeit sind
es gut
150.000 menschen und infektionen an
jedem tag
kann es sein dass sich deswegen das
budget für öffentlichkeitsarbeit des
gesundheitsministers ver 40 8 sprich für
impfung nur ein schlechtes produkt muss
derart teuer vermarktet werden oder gar
mit zwang aufgenötigt hätten wir einen
guten impfstoff gegen ein wirklich
gefährliches virus es gebe einen
schwarzmarkt für impfstoff und keine
impfpflicht gesetze
der bundestag wird zudem über
nebenhaushalte immer weiter entmachtet
das sondervermögen bundeswehr wird
technisch womöglich die blaupause für
milliarden positionen die künftig neben
der schuldenbremse stehen das war ein
zitat des finanzministers was treffen
das bedeutet sie stehen neben dem
bundeshaushalt so kann man auch eben mal
200 million schuss klima versprechen
über ein klima und transformationsländer
vermögen das bereits sehr hohe rücklagen
hat und trotzdem auf punkt nochmals
milliarden an neu zuweisungen bekommen
sollen der klimafonds kann dann
langweilig ohne rücksicht auf die
schuldenbremse etwa 40 milliarden euro
pro jahr ausgeben über ein zehntel des
bundeshaushalts 40 milliarden euro
entsprechend 205 arbeitsstunden die
jeder einkommensteuerzahler zur
erwirtschaftung wird malochen müssen
also jedes jahr einen ganzen monat für
die sogenannte energiewende und das ist
noch nicht einmal der gesamte frondienst
wahnsinn
[Applaus]
das sondervermögen bundeswehr bringt
haushalterisch ich betone haushalterisch
gleich mehrere dammbrüche richtig wäre
es natürlich alle verteidigungsausgaben
entsprechend dem grundsatz der jerich
kite regulär im kernhaushalt
einzustellen im vorliegenden entwurf des
bundeswehr sondervermögens gesetzes
steht ihr durch zitat eine
veranschlagung der ausgaben des
sondervermögens im bundeshaushalt ist
wegen des mehrjährigen umsetzungszeit
raums nicht sinnvoll nun sehr viele
haushalts vorhaben sind über jerich und
unser instrumentarium enthält genau
dafür die werkzeuge der über jährigen
verpflichtungsermächtigung und der
übertragbarkeit von mitteln in die
folgejahre es geht also auch ohne
sondervermögen dann die präsident lose
absicherung per grundgesetzänderung
präsident wir es noch nie dagewesen eine
durch künftige bundestage nur noch mit
zwei-drittel-mehrheit änderbar
haushaltsposition ist meines erachtens
verfassungsrechtlich hoch bedenklich
soll das nun die vorlage für neue
ausnahmesituationen werden andere kriege
weitere pandemie neue jahrhundert
herausforderungen weitere existenzielle
zeitenwenden weitere nebenhaushalte ab
jetzt jährlich wiederkehrend der
kernhaushalt spiegelt dann nur noch
einen teil der wirklichkeit und genau da
laufen dahin
das sondervermögen bekommt sogar eine
eigene kreditermächtigung das ist ein
rückfall in die zeit vor der
schuldenbremse als er 2009 und früher
und mangels tilgungsplan findet die
tilgung des sondervermögens am
sankt-nimmerleins-tag stadt erinnern wir
an dieser stelle kurz an den fdp-antrag
19 10 616 schuldenbremse stärken es muss
künftig ein verbindlicher tilgungsplan
über die dauer eines konjunkturzyklus
auch für notsituationen
festgelegt werden tempi passati lange
vergangenen zeiten der fdp
und dann erinnern wir uns an den
europäischen nebenhaushalt next
generation der 20 21 unter vorwand
corona etabliert wurde schon 2022 soll
nun der nächste eu schulden vorkommen
dieses mal angeblich zur deckung von
kriegsfolgen nur ein jahr später also
bereits das nächste einmalige temporäre
eu gemeinschaftsschulden programm trage
gab dem baby sogar schon einen namen
resilienz fonds oder heißen ich sag dir
hier im haus am 25 februar 20 21 und das
war eigentlich fast prophetisch vor
mehrere der bundestag bei next
generation eu in form einer sogenannten
begrenzten einzelermächtigung beteiligt
das ist bei 800 milliarden euro ein
schlechter witz und einen dammbruch wenn
dieser damm einmal gebrochen ist dann
wird brüssel immer wieder riesige
begrenzte einzelsummen zu lasten
deutscher bonität aufnehmen und sie
großzügig nach süd europa und frankreich
um verteilen der heutige vorschlag
stellt das haushaltsrecht des bundestags
gemäß artikel 110 grundgesetz zur
disposition meine worte vor genau einem
jahr ja genau so sind wir jetzt wieder
hier ein jahr später dazu kommt dann
vorgestern noch diese meldung die eu
staats und regierungschef wollen noch in
dieser woche einen weiteren wiederaufbau
vor auf den weg bringen all das erfährt
der bundestages der zeitung die
bundesregierung hatte uns im ausschuss
keine auskunft gegeben obwohl
eu-ratspräsident michelle dazu
feststellt zitat die ansichten der eu
mitgliedstaaten zum vor unterscheiden
sich nicht im geringsten also auch nicht
die des deutschen finanzministers da
schrillen alle alarmglocken denn was
michelle makro und trage wollen ist ja
bekannt alle wissen es nur der deutsche
bundestag soll es noch nicht wissen nur
haften und zahlen sollen die deutschen
dafür billionen schwer wir sollen unter
notstands vorwand heimlich in die
illegale transfer und haftungsunion
geführt werden
so wird faktisch eine europäische
souveränität begründet was ja hier
inzwischen ganz offen ausgesprochen wird
was aber per definition eine abschaffung
der deutschen souveränität bedeutet und
was eindeutig verfassungswidrig ist
unser versprechen der zur relation damit
komme ich zum schluss sowohl beim
haushaltsnotstand als auch bei der
impfpflicht auf basis des dauerhaften
pandemischen ausnahmezustands aller
lauterbach halten wir es mit willy
brandt mehr mit dem notstand spiel
sollte um die freiheit einzuschränken
wird uns auf den barrikaden zur
verteidigung der demokratie finden auch
das lange ist der spd
[Applaus]
dieter böhringer war das der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion für in der schlussrunde zum
haushaltsgesetz
2022 auf ihn von sven christian kindler
der haushaltspolitische sprecher der
grünen-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
geschehen und am ende einer intensiven
ersten lesung der ersten haushaltswoche
zum haus am 22 und ich finde es hat es
nun mal sehr guten dieser woche gezeigt
insbesondere nach gestern und nach etwas
mehr als 100 tagen neuer regierungen
diese koalition ist handlungsfähig und
stellt sich diesen krisen entschlossen
die wir gerade erleben
ich habe nette ein haushalt vorgelegt
der auf zentrale krisen eingegangen ist
auf die krone pandemie auf die
klimakrise und jetzt haben wir eine
schreckliche neue krise mit in europa
und ich wundere mich schon über die
kritik an union an dem parlamentarischen
und regierungs verfahren zum haushalt
ist doch völlig klar dass wir auf diesen
russischen angriffskrieg jetzt im
weiteren verfahren reagieren müssen noch
einiges ändern müssen im etat und
deswegen ist es richtig dass diese
regierung noch eine ergänzung zu hause
erfahren vorlegen wird das ist notwendig
denn
wir stellen diesen haushalt in einer der
schwersten krisen in europa seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg auf es ist der grösste
land krieg in europa seit 1945 natürlich
können wir und die regierung gestern
nicht alles wissen was wir konkret heute
noch finanzieren müssen den nächsten
tagen wir haben heute den 25 märz 2022
30 tag des krieges und wir wissen noch
nicht konkret was wir alles finanzieren
müssen aber wir wissen sehr konkret wir
werden nicht tatenlos zusehen die werden
nicht business as usual machen wir
werden das wären entschlossen handeln
und dass das notwendig ist auch konkret
finanzieren
und das ist das entscheidende für diese
koalition wir packen sie krisen
entschlossen an und wir lassen die
vielen menschen die jetzt zu uns auch
vor diesem schrecklichen krieg fliehen
nicht alleine lassen nicht in stich
gelassen aber auch die bürgerinnen
bürger hier in deutschland wegen fossile
preissteigerungen nicht im stich
gelassen unternehmen und selbstständige
unterstützen wir jetzt von kriegen
deswegen hat diese koalition ein erstes
entlastungs paket vorgelegt und jetzt
legen und deutschland zweites gerechtes
entlastungspaket vor dass darwin wir
konkret mit energieeffizienz von einer
beschleunigen energieunabhängigkeit und
das ist genau richtig wir binden
klimaschutz und soziale gerechtigkeit
wir spielen es nicht genau aus wie sie
union noch bedenken beides zusammen der
koalition
und jetzt habe ich die rufe aus der
union gehört unter anderen von herr
dobrindt war von anderen ja dann steigt
aber doch die neuverschuldung rascher
lockt das ist richtig die
neuverschuldung wird steigen an der
stelle aber was ist denn die alternative
nichts machen ist auch keine alternative
das habe ich auch nicht gefordert das
heißt wir müssen auch konkrete
vorschläge machen wie man das so wie die
finanzieren will haben sie in dieser
woche hier konkrete einsparvorschläge
gebracht wir haben sie nicht gehört von
ihnen haben sie konkrete vorschläge
macht für eine gerechtere steuerpolitik
habe ich auch nicht gehört im gegenteil
otto fricke hat ja wie lange müsste ja
gerade präsentiert was sie alles an
mehrausgaben gefordert haben sie haben
konkret weiter deutliche steuersenkungen
gefordert ohne sinn und verstand die zum
teil übrigens europarechtswidrig sind
und dann will ich mal konkret sagen so
geht keine seriöse finanzpolitik
man kann nicht man kann nicht neue
kredite hier kritisieren gleichzeitig
strukturelle hohe steuersenkung fordern
und dafür keine gegenfinanzierung
anbieten man kann die prinzipien von
logik mathematik nicht außer kraft
setzen liebe union dass eine bruder
finanzpolitik die sich im bundestag
machen
und für uns heißt klar wir machen auch
keine haushalts und finanzpolitik sich
nur starr an ideologischen
kennziffern orientiert sondern wir
betrachten die realität das zeichnet sie
koalition aus wir handeln finanzieren
das notwendige nicht mehr aber auch
nicht weniger
wir werden diese krise nicht einsparen
sollen wir eine antwort mit einer
aktiven finanzpolitik
und ich glaube wir uns das ja auch
finanziell durch diesen angriff stieg
von ladenwaagen ukraine vor ganz neuen
finanziellen herausforderungen europa
stehen der bundeskanzler hat zu recht
von einer zeitenwende gesprochen das
betrifft extrem viele bereiche in
deutschland und in europa und eine
zeitwende heißt nicht dass sich alles in
ein paar monaten danach wieder vorbei
ist und nicht verzieht sich
längerfristig wenn wir jetzt sehen was
es auch verfolgen auch schon für unsere
gesellschaften hat dann sehen wir dass
der massive wirtschaftliche und soziale
folgen haben dass viele menschen zu uns
kommen denen wir hier zuflucht und
integration anbieten wollen wir haben
eine massive humanitäre und monetäre
dramatische lage in der ukraine und den
ländern als nachbarländern wir haben da
ganz große bedrohung der
ernährungssicherheit weltweit und klar
ist für uns wir müssen diese
herausforderung jetzt angehen und
deswegen werden doch im ergänzungsbedarf
konkret reagieren und das blut winde
finanzieren was wir jetzt brauchen
aber ich will ein anderer punkt auf
hinaus diese folgen von nicht gerade
gesprochen habe die werden nicht einfach
am 31 12 2009 22 vorbei sein und dann
ist alles wieder wie vorher wir kommen
zurück zu einem status quo und
normalität davor das wird es nicht sein
ich traue jeweils aktuell keine prognose
zu ob wir im nächsten jahr angesichts
der pandemie auch des schrecklichen
krieges und seiner folgen wieder findet
er normal zustanden deutschland europa
kommen werden auch aktuell hat die
europäische kommission klar gesagt dass
sie zu recht überlegt die ausweich
klausel für den stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt auf 2023 wieder zu ziehen
und es kann daher und der realität sehr
gut sein dass wir auch in deutschland
2023 wieder die notfall schräge der
schuldenbremse ziehen müssen ich sage
sehr konkret niemand hier wünsche ich
das weil das bedeutet dass wir weiter in
einer krisenbedingten notfall bedingten
lage sind aber wenn es so sein wird dass
wir weiter in einer finanziellen notlage
sind dann müssen wir auch entsprechend
handeln und entschlossen auch das
finanzieren was notwendig ist
und jetzt die ersten haus ist woche im
bundestag auch unsere arbeit im
parlament los wir haben eine sehr gute
grundlage mit dem ersten
regierungsentwurf wir werden ergänzungs
haushalte konkret vorlegen wir werden
diesen entwurf nutzen image verbessern
im konkreten parlamentarische verfahren
und wie auf einem punkt noch mal hinweis
wenn wir zu recht viel geld zur
verfügung stellen dann werden wir es aus
jedoch darauf achten dass das geld
wirksam und effizient auch eingesetzt
wird die häuser müssen mit dem geld auch
sinnvoll umgehen auch dass wir im
haushaltsausschuss konkret kontrollieren
ich freue mich auf die beratungen auch
mit der demokratischen opposition wären
eine große herausforderung in diesen
zeiten das werden sehr intensive wochen
und monate für uns werden und lassen uns
aber sehr gut zusammenarbeiten vielen
dank
[Applaus]
der gründonnerstag hat hier schon mal
angekündigt dass er sich ja auch die
weiteren beratungen erfreut auf ihn
folgten janine wissler
sie sitzt im finanzausschuss ist aber
natürlich
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir sind bestürzt über die bilder aus
der ukraine
zerstörte wohnhäuser millionen menschen
auf der flucht familien
auseinandergerissen werden verletzte und
tote
putins angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
ist ein verbrechen und durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen putbus muss die
kampfhandlungen sofort einstellen die
truppen zurückziehen die linke lehnt
krieg als mittel der politik entschieden
ab unsere solidarität gilt den menschen
in der ukraine die um ihr leben fürchten
und unsere solidarität geht den menschen
in russland die gegen putins kriegskurs
protestieren trotz repressionen und
polizeigewalt ihr protest ist der
schlüssel für ein anderes russland
und er danke den menschen die befristete
versorgen und das ist gut dass die
staaten der europäischen union
geflüchtete aufnehmen auch die das
bisher nicht getan haben aber das muss
für alle menschen gelten die für bon ho
und krieg fliehen auf die menschen in
bella russisch polnischen grenzgebiet
auch sie brauchen hilfe und keine zäune
und illegale pusch max meine damen und
herren
in einem friedenspolitischen appell
haben sich über 600 prominente gegen das
geplante 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
ausgesprochen
eine massive hochrüstung der bundeswehr
hilft den menschen in der ukraine nicht
schon jetzt
übersteigen die verteidigungsausgaben
der nato-staaten die russischen um das
fast 20 fachen ein neues vertrösten
macht diese welt nicht sicherer ganz im
gegenteil
und auch das viel beschworene bild von
der kaputtgespart bundeswehr stimmt doch
einfach nicht der verteidigungshaushalt
ist seit 2000 14 und 40 prozent
gestiegen auf 50 milliarden euro
jährlich ja viel geld für sickert durch
dubiose verrät betreibt beraterverträge
oder ein beschaffungswesen bei denen die
rüstungsindustrie die preise selbst
festlegt aber das problem löst man doch
nicht dass man damit man noch mehr geld
reinsteckt in dieses schwarze loch
würde gerne umgesetzt würde fast jeder
fünfte euro im bundeshaushalt ausgegeben
werden für militär und dann sollen sie
die ausrüstung noch im grundgesetz fest
schreiben die bekäme damit
verfassungsrang was für ein brüssel bei
den rüstungskonzernen knallen die
sektkorken die aktienkurse schießen in
die höhe und das zeigt doch es geht eben
nicht nur um warme unterwäsche für die
truppe nein es geht um bewaffnete
drohnen es geht um atomwaffenfähige
tarnkappenjets und ausgerechnet eine
grüne außenministerin politik regiert
jetzt für nukleare abschreckung meine
damen und herren aber war es doch ein
fehler dass die abrüstungsverträge der
vergangenheit gekündigt oder gar nicht
erst unterzeichnet wurden sicherheit und
frieden wird es doch nicht geben doch
durch noch mehr waffen auf dieser welt
[Applaus]
größten
weizenexporteure schon jetzt gibt es
massive
preissteigerungen hungersnöte drohen
auch durch die klimakrise und in dieser
situation kürzt die ampel die mittel zur
hungerbekämpfung und das ist fatal
ja das gibt sie auf die krisengewinner
die die profitieren von steigenden
energie und benzinpreisen und ein
großteil der preissteigerung
verbleibt bei den mineralölkonzernen
durch müsste man ansetzen wenn man
verbraucher schützen will und auch bei
rwe und e on auch dort stiegen die
gewinne deutlich auf post mehr
verbraucher höchste zeit für die
wiedereinführung der staatlichen
stromkreis aufsicht darüber sollten wir
reden und um die energiewende endlich
voranzubringen und an dieser stelle
seien wo mal angemerkt dass unser neuer
gaslieferant katar nicht nur die
menschenrechte mit füßen tritt sondern
auch beteiligt war im krieg gegen den
jemen wo gut 300.000 menschen gestorben
sind im jemen was bitte hat das mit
werte basierter außenpolitik
kurzfristig brauchen wir zielgerichtete
entlastung für menschen mit geringen
oder durchschnittlichen einkommen aber
die entlastung muss vom einkommen
abhängen und nicht von der größe und ihr
spritverbrauch des autos und ihr
entlastungspaket ist nicht nachhaltig es
ist sozial unausgewogen wenn die
alleinerziehende verkäuferin besonders
genau so viel bekommt wie der
einkommensmillionäre
und dann können nicht der
gesundheitsminister der noch im
wahlkampf für die bürgerversicherung
geworben hat auch noch steigende
krankenkassenbeiträge an am gleichen tag
die senkung der öpnv abreise das ist
richtig aber ich frage sie warum denn
nur für drei monate und die größte
belastung für viele menschen sind
übrigens die mieten da haben wir vom
finanzminister noch nie den vorschlag
gehört das ist der rabatte geben müsste
weil reicht der mieten sind preis
deckelungen aus sicht der fdp ja
bekanntlich teufelszeug meine damen und
herren der haushalt zeigt ihre
prioritäten die versprochene
kindergrundsicherung findet im haushalt
ebenso wenig statt wie verbesserungen
bei hartz iv der kampf gegen kinderarmut
wurde vertagt 100 milliarden fürs
militär über nacht einer milliarde für
den pflege bonus für pflegekräfte wo ist
dann das 100 milliarden programm zur
bildung für krankenhäuser für öpnv für
digitalisierung die riesigen
herausforderungen des klimaschutzes
werden wir doch gar nicht stemmen können
wenn man die schuldenbremse beibehält
meine damen und herren und das hat
letzter satz präsidentin denn das
hundegesetz schon geändert wird dann
sollten wir doch keine schattenhaushalte
im grundgesetz fest schreiben oder
sollten wir die schuldenbremse
abschaffen und natürlich brauchen wir
endlich eine gerechte steuerreform stehe
hohe vermögen stärker zu besteuern und
die soziale ungleichheit zu mindern und
dieser vorliegende haushaltsentwurf wird
den krisen unserer zeit und in großen
versprechen der ampel von fortschritt
und respekt leider in keinster weise
gerecht
das kritisiert von whistler guter
versuch der linken und ob sie direkt
antworten kann nun derjenige der für
diesen haushaltsentwurf zuständig ist
nämlich bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner sport hat der bundesminister der
finanzen christian binden
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die
haushaltswoche intensiv verfolgt eine
der schönsten
nachrichten dieser woche stammt vom
kollegen burri der hier eben erklärt hat
er sei unlängst vater geworden
herzlichen glückwunsch dazu er hat es
er hat dieses schöne nachricht zum
anlass genommen ein plädoyer zu halten
für generationengerechtigkeit und solide
haushalte sie haben das getan in
quantitativer hinsicht
und diese überzeugung teile ich deshalb
hat sich ja die ampel koalition in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag auch in aller klarheit
zur schuldenbremse des grundgesetzes
bekannt zur generationengerechtigkeit
zur generationengerechtigkeit kollege
burri gehört aber nicht nur eine
quantitative betrachtung der
staatsfinanzen sondern auch eine
qualitative betrachtung der öffentlichen
haushalte diese koalition hält die
eckwerte der vorgängerregierung von 99 7
milliarden euro nettokreditaufnahme ein
aber wir tun mehr für die bildung wir
tun mehr für den sozialen ausgleich wie
investieren mehr in infrastruktur und
wir sichern die überlebenschancen der
menschheit durch anstrengungen beim
klimaschutz
jetzt nachdem unterschiede auf
wir stellen uns der quantitativen und
der qualitativen konsolidierung unserer
staatsfinanzen
jetzt haben sie vielfach bezug genommen
auf
der sondervermögen zur stärkung der
bündnis und verteidigungsfähigkeit
gerade wurde es im zusammenhang mit dem
wort schattenhaushalt verwendet frau
kollegin ein sondervermögen das im
grundgesetz steht das steht alles andere
im schatten noch mehr öffentlichkeit als
eine verfassungsrechtliche absicherung
im grundgesetz ist hier gar nicht
vorstellbar
und kolleginnen und kollegen der union
sprechen jetzt mal von der solidität der
haushalte und von rekordverschuldung
durch diese zusätzlichen 100 milliarden
kolleginnen und kollegen ich rate ihnen
davon ab dies sofort zu setzen die 100
milliarden euro des sondervermögens sind
ja nur notwendig weil über viele jahre
die bundeswehr vernachlässigt wurde wer
angesichts dieses sondervermögens die
solidität der bundesregierung infrage
stellt der muss zugleich erklären dass
er selbst unsolide mit der bundeswehr
umgegangen
ich bitte sie also um zustimmung und
eine eine auch konstruktive begleitung
unserer arbeit hier die koalition hat
ein zweites entlastungs paket
beschlossen ein erstes gab es bereits
ein zweites habe ich hier angekündigt
seine eckpunkte sind nun bekannt es gibt
einen steuerrabatt bespritzt ja in den
zeitungen gelesen dass in dem
zusammenhang von einer gießkanne
gesprochen worden ist die wahrheit ist
dass in der ganzen breite die menschen
von steigenden energiepreisen betroffen
sind sie zahlen darüber in der ganzen
breite übrigens auch steuersätze nach
menge oder auf den umsatz und deshalb
ist es natürlich auch gerechtfertigt
befristete die ganze breite der
gesellschaft zu entlasten denn auf ihren
schultern stehen wir alle
es wird geben einer energie pauschale
als
steuerlichen zuschuss für alle
steuerpflichtigen erwerbstätigen in höhe
von 300 euro
das soll eine spürbare entlastung seien
gerade angesichts der steigenden
energiepreise wir berücksichtigen dabei
die individuelle leistungsfähigkeit weil
wir nämlich den steuertarif der lohn und
einkommenssteuer nutzen um diese energie
pauschale gerecht zu verteilen es ist
der politische wille der koalition
es ist der politische wille der
koalition dass damit die menschen auch
wirklich spürbar entlastet werden und
deshalb halte ich es für richtig dass
wir auf die
sozialabgaben flicht auch die
sozialversicherungspflicht bei dieser
energie pauschale verzichten damit ihr
wirklich eine spürbare endlich zum
erreichen
der familienbonus einer einmalzahlung
für grundsicherungsempfänger und vor
allen dingen auch
zusätzliche investitionen in die
energieeffizienz kommen hinzu für das
jahr 2022 rechne ich mit haushalts
folgen in höhe von 17 milliarden euro
also etwa in der größenordnung des
ersten entlastungspaket wenn sie mehr
fordern seitens der cdu csu
dann habe ich dafür verständnis
mehr fordern kann man immer aber wer
fordert muss zugleich sagen wie er es
finanziert was sie nicht tun können ist
verschuldung zu kritisieren auf der
einen seite auf der anderen seite aber
immer nur nach mehr und schneller zu
rufen komme zum schluss frau präsident
sind
komme zum schlüssel präsidentin das
zweite entlastungspaket wird teil des
ergänzungs haushaltes sein ich
beabsichtige das bundeskabinett am 27
april mit diesem ergänzungs haushalt zu
befassen es solle enthaltenen maßnahmen
im zusammenhang mit dem ukraine krieg es
ist transparent dass deshalb auch ein
ergänzungs haushalt vorgelegt wird damit
das parlament prüfen kann ob es wirklich
nur aufgaben im zusammenhang mit der
bewältigung der folgen des ukraine
krieges sind die maßnahmen sollen im
einzelplan 16 nach meinem vorschlag
etatisiert werden und genügend damit den
ansprüchen an haushaltswahrheit und
haushaltsklarheit vielen dank
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
hat mich zu hause sein weiteres vorgehen
zum ergänzungs haushalt an hatten
natürlich auch noch einmal die
entlastungen verteidigt auf die sich die
ampel koalition geeinigt haben oder zum
beispiel auch den sonderfonds bundeswehr
in höhe von 100 milliarden euro florian
oßner antwortet jetzt auf den
finanzminister erst mitglied der
unionsfraktion und sitzt im
haushaltsausschuss
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
bitte lassen sie mich ein paar worte zu
beginn erstmal daran gehen verlieren zu
meinen vorrednern zum herrn
bundesfinanzminister gehe ich dann aber
noch mehr separat intensiver ein also
die spd beginnt hier heute mit der
schlussrunde haushalt damit
wahlkampf zu machen für die spd
nordrhein-westfalens die fdp beginnt
heute ausschließlich die gesamte
redezeit nur zum oppositions bashing
kein wort zum aktuellen haushalt nur
opposition spacing und die grünen der
grünen-vertreter er spricht von der
klimakrise und fordert von uns lösungen
für diesen haushalt ein wie hilflos
liebe ampelkoalition ehre ist das denn
der haushaltsentwurf des
bundesfinanzministers die auf den
haushalt eingehen das möchte ich lobend
erwähnen in diesem zusammenhang mutet
aber uns als haushälter doch schon
einiges zu statt einer
übertragenen sinne kinder überraschung
ist es eine lindner überraschung
gewordener aber leider ein technisches
überraschung sei weder spannung spielen
noch schokolade sondern stattdessen
schulden
schieflagen und schattenhaushalte
dieser dieser haushalt ist und bleibt
eine wundertüte und für uns als
parlamentarier da bin ich wissen was
noch alles auf uns zukommt
in der tat wirklich schwierig bereits
jetzt wurden ja bereits so genannte
ergänzungs haushalte angekündigt also so
sieht wahrlich keine vertrauenswürdige
finanzpolitik aus
anspruch und wirklichkeit sind bei den
vorgelegten zahlen unser erstes beispiel
als grundlage für die berechnung der
einnahmen und ausgabenseite wurde ein
wirtschaftswachstum von sage und
schreibe 3,6 prozentpunkte unter steht
beim privaten konsum sogar ein anstieg
um sechs prozentpunkte gegenüber dem
feuer wie diese ungemein optimistischen
zahlen geht es doch begründbar sind auch
vor dem hintergrund der schrecklichen
ukraine kriegs bleibt ein geheimnis des
finanzministeriums seriöse
haushaltspolitik die definitiv anders
zweites beispiel die arbeitslosenquote
soll von 5,7 prozentpunkte auf 5,1
prozentpunkte sinken was
425.000 zusätzliche beschäftigte in
deutschland bedeuten würde bitte
verstehen sie mich nicht falsch ich
würde mich sehr darüber freuen nur
allein der glaube daran fehlt mir zudem
sollen die steuereinnahmen um 19
milliarden euro höher sein als in 20 21
beim besten willen wir dürfen uns die
zahlen nicht einfach schön rechnen liebe
ampel
rund 200 milliarden euro neue schulden
werden damit den zukünftigen
generationen jetzt schon aufs auge
gedrückt gigantisch und das sind die
ergänzungs haushalte noch nicht dabei
und auch sie dürfen noch nicht denken
das schuldenmachen wäre dann so
abgefrühstückt der bundesfinanzminister
betonte gebetsmühlenartig wie soeben
geschehen das ja auch 20 23 die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten möchte
wie der begriff schon bereit sagt ist es
ja eine bremse und keine schulden
vermeidung also plant die ampel bereits
jetzt schon bis 20 26 in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung
weitere 42 6 milliarden euro zusätzliche
schulden 60 milliarden euro ist und ob
wurden bereits rückwirkend in das letzte
auf verbucht im nachtragshaushalt 20 21
für uns als cdu csu stars
verfassungswidrig wer bitte schön soll
das alles noch bezahlen lieber rot grün
gelbe bundesregierung
aber damit damit noch nicht genug die
tilgungen werden deutlich später
beginnen statt in 20 23 des zur
generationengerechtigkeit mein kollege
yannik buhl schon eingegangen ist
sondern nun in 20 28 werden gestreckt
auf 20 58
also 16 jahre länger als ursprünglich
geplant ab 20 28 müssen also jedes jahr
trotz gestreckter 31 jahre tilgung über
elf milliarden euro pro jahr
zurückgezahlt werden was die
investitionsmöglichkeiten in die zukunft
massiv einschränkt apropos investitionen
vollmundig verkündet dass jahrzehnte
zukunftsinvestitionen sein und
angebrochen wir als cdu und csu haben in
den letzten jahren die investitionen von
28 auf 50 milliarden euro jährlich
anwachsen lassen bis 20 26 soll nun
diese auf diesem niveau verbleiben also
inflationsbereinigt sinken die
investitionen damit sogar über den
zeitzer auch also wirklich liebe ampel
mehr etikettenschwindel geht nicht
neben all diesen faktoren bringt der
haushalt noch immense riesig im
sozialbereich sonderzahlungen an die
rentenversicherung werden eingestellt
die kosten der unterkunft und die und
das arbeitslosengeld werden
runtergefahren und der gesamte
gesundheitsbereich ist massiv corona
bedingt in schieflage geraten deshalb
risikovorsorge seitens des
bundesfinanzministers fragezeichen
fehlanzeige es wird einfach so getan als
gäbe es all diese probleme nicht herr
minister sie gefährden damit massiv die
stabilität unserer
sozialversicherungssysteme
die veranschlagten knapp 458 milliarden
euro werden bei weitem nicht die wünsche
der hungrigen ampel koalitionäre stillen
und tragen zudem noch auf die falschen
prioritäten er
zu dem spiegel der regierungsentwurf
auch nicht die sorgen und nöte der
menschen in unserem land während der
mittelstand absäuft aufgrund der hohen
hohen energiepreise beschließt die ampel
eine mehr als fragwürdige energie
pauschale die am ende keinem hilft und
neue bürokratie verursacht deutschland
braucht keine mogelpackung darf nicht
mit schlusslicht europa sein wenn es um
die steuerlichen entlastungen geht
ich darf abschließend zusammenfassende
keine reserven in der mittelfristigen
finanzplanung keine risikovorsorge keine
ehrlichen prognosen sagen
unüberschaubare schuldenmacherei und zu
weniger investitionen in die zukunft
also ein haushalt der das papier nicht
wert ist auf dem er gedruckt wurde
herzliches vergelt's gott fürs zuhören
harsche kritik von florian mussner
mitglied des haushaltsausschusses wie
auch die nächste rednerin bettina
hagedorn ist mitglied der
sozialdemokraten hier im deutschen
bundestag und spricht hier nur einmal so
schlussrunde des haushaltsgesetzes das
dann überwiesen wird in entsprechenden
ausschüsse und otto noch weiter
diskutiert wird
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen
kommen wir zurück zur sachebene
herr kollege herr kollege
lieber herr kollege und ich
habe dass die zusagen die es nicht
wissen ich bin seit 20 jahren im
haushaltsausschuss das ist heute das
einundzwanzigste mal dass sich in der
schlussrunde einer ersten lesung eines
bundeshaushaltes bin und ich dachte ich
habe schon alles erlebt und diese lesung
hat mir gezeigt nein das ist nicht so
und weil das so ist lieber kollege aus
nach kann ich mich auch sehr lebhaft an
drei große koalition erinnern wo ich mit
den kolleginnen und kollegen der union
besser zusammengearbeitet habe als im
haushaltsausschuss als dass manche in
der öffentlichkeit wahr haben wollten
und weil das so ist bin ich bitter von
ihnen enttäuscht nicht nur von ihrer
rede jetzt sondern von leider vers
eingebacken beiträgen diese woche weil
es ist ja die quadratur des kreises und
unser alter chef franz müntefering hätte
gesagt es würde reichen vierte klasse
grundschule sauerland in vier
grundrechenarten dass das was sie hier
die ganze woche mantraartig vortragen
einerseits immer neue forderungen jetzt
gerade wieder steuersenkung und doof
regel kann seine liste noch ein bisschen
verlängern auf der anderen seite also
mehrausgaben keine kürzungsvorschläge
natürlich keine steuererhöhungen sondern
auch nicht bei den reichen sondern
steuerentlastung und dass das ganze dann
natürlich und solid ist und dass sie uns
und dem finanzminister und soliden
haushalt vor dass sie dass sie das hier
bemängeln das ist geradezu dass es
geradezu j
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen diese
ampel regierung ist gestartet schon bei
den koalitionsverhandlungen in dem
bewusstsein dass wir große krisen zu
schultern haben die lieber kollege burri
eben sehr wichtig für die nächste
generation sind und zwar nicht man kann
krisen meistens nicht bewältigen indem
man einspart sondern man muss schon
investieren um den kindern auch eine
gute infrastruktur eine gute zukunft zu
ermöglichen
die klimakrise die bewältigung des
klimawandels ganz große zentrale aufgabe
dieser ampel regierung zu der wir uns
bekennen auf der anderen seite eine
zweijährige corona pandemie von der wir
hofften dass wir sie bald bewältigen
würden dann gut der impfstoffe und auch
dann guter prognosen was unsere
wirtschaftliche entwicklung anbelangt
und dann jetzt der 24 februar unter
überfall putins auf die ukraine mit
heute noch gar nicht absehbaren folgen
denn wie es nicht wie lange er dauert
wir wissen nicht wie viele tote wie
viele opfer wie viele flüchtlinge
erbringen wird und wir wissen auch nicht
was dieser krieg mit der wirtschaft
nicht nur in europa und in deutschland
sondern in der ganzen welt macht und
alle die mal haushaltspolitik gemacht
haben wissen dass diese eckdaten nämlich
die prognosen für steuern wir wohl
einnehmen werden wie für sozialbeiträge
und eingeteilt werden wie viel wir
ausgeben müssen für kurzarbeitergeld und
andere dinge die uns immer auch uns in
der großen koalition gut durch die krise
gebracht haben wir haben das gemeinsam
gemacht und erstmals wir gemeinsam
gemacht haben das kritisieren sie heute
dass es komplett geschichtsvergessen
bei der sufis
weil das so ist weil das ist liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist es
ausgesprochen klug dass dieser regierung
sie verabredet hat jetzt ein erster
entwurf vorzulegen den herr merz hier
verspottet hat dass er kernhaushalt
genannt wurde in wahrheit ist es aber so
und es ist auch alternativlos sonder
regierung wenn sie uns als parlament so
früh wie möglich mit den
haushaltsberatungen einbeziehen will
darum war es richtig dass die regierung
ihre beratung ihrer ressort gespräche ja
schon abgeschlossen waren es wäre keine
krieg begann dass sie uns diesen
haushalts vorgelegt haben wir haben
diese woche debattiert und beschämt ist
es aber dass viele rednerinnen und
redner der cdu so getan haben und damit
der öffentlichkeit sand in die augen
gestreut haben jetzt noch eine harmlose
formulierung man könnte auch sagen
belogen haben darüber in dem sie
kritisiert haben was in diesem haushalt
alles noch nicht drin steht kann es ja
auch gar nicht weil es gibt ja einen
ergänzungs haushalt am 27 april werden
wir hatten es ja gerade gesagt uns damit
befassen und wir haushälter pause sie
sind seit gestern nach
haushaltsausschuss sie wissen ist doch
so wie wir werden bis zum 19 mal
bereinigungssitzung diese haushalte
zusammen führen wir werden sie verändert
denn es ist das budgetrecht des
parlamentes und wir werden auch den 100
milliarden auf 100 milliarden topf für
den für die bundeswehr beraten
wir werden dafür sorgen dass es starke
parlamentarische rechte gibt in den
entscheidungen und in den kontrollen für
dieses für diesen etat und das ist in
anbetracht der krisen und der
herausforderung vor der wir stehen eine
sehr angemessene eine
verantwortungsvolle arbeit und wissen
sie was jeder der das kritisiert sollte
lieber sagen was ist eigentlich ihre
rolle in einer solchen krise was
erwarten die menschen von ihnen sie
erwarten von ihnen dass sie konstruktiv
mitmachen ich würde mir wünschen dass
sie daraus dazu zurückkommt vielen kann
[Applaus]
kleinen moment bitte noch
so jetzt ein bisschen was daneben
gegangen wenig das wesen reparieren das
gibt mir ist es
darauf hinzuweisen
dass der hinweis dass man zum schluss
kommt nicht den schlusspunkt ersetzt
sondern dass auch
angekündigte zusammenfassungen und
ähnliches in die redezeit schon von
vornherein eingepreist werden ich will
ganz ausdrücklich mich darüber freuen
dass otto fricke das heute auch mit
seinem shakespeare zitat geschafft hat
aber auch für die letzten beiträge in
dieser schlussrunde gilt es sie sprechen
zum schluss auf kosten ihrer kolleginnen
und kollegen wenn sie auf meinen signal
nicht reagieren
wir fahren fort in der debatte das wort
hat der abgeordnete norbert kleinwächter
für die auf die fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin sie haben
vollkommen recht wir müssen hier vorne
was reparieren nämlich den haushalt und
frau kollegin hagedorn also ich bin
jetzt weit davon entfernt den herrn
kollegen russland zu verteidigen aber
wenn sie eine rede die einfach nur die
realität beschreibt enttäuscht dann
zeigt es einfach nur dass ihr haushalt
reinste träumerei ist und ganz weit weg
von der realität und sie werden auch von
mir enttäuscht sein denn auch ich will
ihnen den spiegel der realität vorhalten
die bundesregierung räumt die
bundesregierung träumt dass man den
feministischen außenpolitik die welt
verbessern könne deutschland allein in
klimawandel bekämpfen könne dass die
europäischen union für die bürgerarbeit
und das 100 milliarden sondern etwa für
die bundeswehr und sofort
verteidigungsfähigkeit aber ich will
ihnen reinen wein einschenken und liebe
damen und herren die wirklichkeit ist
ein f 35 kampfjets wird halt nicht
morgen geliefert werden un-soldaten
entsteht auch nicht per mausklick und
die europäische union arbeitet auch
nicht für uns sondern nimmt unser geld
verteilt es um die projekte der
europäischen union scheitern regelmäßig
ihre forstet ineffektiv und ihre
geldpolitik führt zur inflation und zu
den großen problemen die wir jetzt
gerade haben die uns alle arme
und die wirklichkeit ist während fried
chicken da draußen demonstrieren denen
sie einreden sie sterben im klimawandel
wenn jetzt nicht sofort irgendwas
passiert verkaufen sie gerade deren
zukunft in alle ewigkeit 14,7 millionen
euro beträgt die implizite staatsschuld
soll heute und sie verschenken immer
weiter sie machen schulden schulden
schulden die die junge generation
bezahlen soll eine junge generation die
arbeiten wird und nichts davon hat die
erwirtschaftet und nichts davon hat er
einen adipösen haushalt finanziert und
nichts davon hat und deswegen rufe ich
an dieser stelle den kindern und
jugendlichen zu wir kämpfen hier für
eure zukunft für eine stabile
gesellschaft mit einem stabilen
wohlstand die diese regierung
spd fdp und aus grünen grundlos
verschenkt
[Applaus]
das opfer auch dieser regierung ist die
rechtsstaatlichkeit regeln gelten
einfach nicht mehr die
maastricht-kriterien längst über bord
geworfen und sie trauen es sich sogar
den haushalt wörtlich reinzuschreiben
direkt in zahlen untereinander zulässige
nettokreditaufnahme 19,1 milliarden euro
nettokreditaufnahme des bundes 99,7
milliarden euro sie schreiben selber
rein wir dürfen uns nicht aber wir
machen es trotzdem ist uns völlig egal
und mal ganz ehrlich herr lindner sie
sind ja gerade so stolz gewesen auf
diese zahlen weil die vorherige
bundesregierung die offensichtlich auch
schon definiert hat ganz ehrlich wenn es
vorher falsch war macht es das nicht
richtiger wenn sie es einfach
wiederholen konsolidierung sieht anders
aus
und weil ihnen das alles nicht reicht
wollen sie ja noch 100 milliarden euro
zusätzlich haben dass freeman sie mal
eben sondervermögen damit sie schulden
aufnehmen können am eigentlichen
haushalt vorbei sie wollen den
dauerhaften
haushalterischen ausnahmezustand und
dass es nicht in ordnung auch wenn ich
ihnen auch wenn ich ihn wirklich zu
gestehen muss dass jetzt gerade dabei
sind neue psychologische methoden für
die schuldnerberatung zu erfinden also
ganz ehrlich da kommt jetzt in zukunft
der überschuldeten pechvogel zum berater
und der kann dann also voll legitim
sagen machen sie sich keine sorgen sie
haben keine schulden sie haben
sondervermögen
so richtig es ist die bundeswehr wieder
zu befähigen machen sie das doch im
regulären haushalt stehen sie zu ihrer
politik setzen sie prioritäten und bauen
sie eben die kosten in den regulären
haushalt einstand parallele welten zu
erschaffen von sondervermögen und von
ergänzungs haushalten die uns irgendwann
einmal erwarten ich erwarte von dieser
bundesregierung dass sie von anfang an
einen ordentlichen haushalt vorliegt
denn wir beraten können mit zahlen die
verlässlich sind und an denen wir
entsprechend arbeiten können
aber ja
bei der schuldnerberatung ist ja auch
eines der zentralen ersten punkte dass
man der realität nicht entflieht sondern
sich ihr stellt und die ist dass
deutschland einfach ausgaben abbauen
muss die verschuldung deutschlands
müsste nicht sein eine gute
bundesregierung würde nicht 36
eineinhalb milliarden euro an die eu
zahlen von dem er nur die hälfte zurück
bekommen in unsinnigen projekten sie
würde nicht 66 milliarden euro in
exzentrischen new stecken sie würde
nicht 21 milliarden euro sma zahlung
haben sie würde eben keinen eu fonds
unterstützen und sie würde die tage zwei
forderungen von deutlich mehr als einer
billion euro mittlerweile zurück holt
die markenrechte kommen sie bitte zum
schluss das wäre ich tue und das geld
ist eigentlich da aber es ist nur
woanders wir brauchen kein
sondervermögen wir müssen auch die
schuldenregel nicht brechen sie müssen
aufhören sich in die tasche zu lügen und
das mit den worten zum fremming setzen
sie ist wie du den fremming weil der
dritte blieben geschlossen
ich bitte sie diesen tunnelblick
aufzugeben vielen herzlichen dank
die kritik von und norbert kleinwächter
hier auch nochmal an den ausgaben die
deutschland innerhalb seiner
mitgliedschaft in der europäischen union
auf ihn folgt nun sebastian schäfer
sebastian schäfer setzt im finanz und
haushaltsausschuss
jeweils und ist mitglied der
grünen-fraktion deutschen und dadurch
die grünen hat nun doch sebastian
schäfer dazu
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen dies sind meine
ersten haushaltsverhandlungen als
mitglied dieses wohnhauses aber auch
eine alte haye sind sie verzeiht mir wie
die geschätzte kollegin mit einer
hagedorn hat mir versichert dass die
rahmenbedingungen unter denen wir diese
verhandlungen führen alles andere als
normal sind wir können im moment viele
entwicklungen nur sehr eingeschränkt
über blicken auf ein schnelles ende des
krieges in der ukraine hoffen wir alle
fast die ganze welt appelliert jeden tag
dringend an putin diesen abscheulichen
überfall auf die ukraine endlich zu
stoppen und die eigenen truppen
zurückzuziehen
aber auch nach einem ende der
kampfhandlungen ist die welt eine andere
fossile energie und rohstoffpreise
werden teuer bleiben umso wichtiger ist
es dass wir so lange wir für eine
übergangszeit noch fossile energien
benötigen unsere abhängigkeiten abbauen
wirtschaftsminister hat dein den
vergangenen wochen bemerkenswerte
erfolge erzielt bei kohle haben wir die
lieferungen aus russland halbiert bei
gas und öl deutlich reduziert und das
werden wir mit hochdruck weiter
vorantreiben
es geht um eine möglichst kurze brücke
ins postfossile zeitalter dass diese
fortschritts koalition entschlossen
erreichen wird wind sonnenenergie und
grüner wasserstoff werden uns in wenigen
jahren unabhängig machen dass es
elementar um die klimakrise zu lösen und
unseren industrie standort zukunftsfähig
und regulieren zu machen
unsere wirtschaft ist durch die pandemie
immer noch belastet viele bürgerinnen
und bürger sind extrem verunsichert die
allensbach zahlen dieser woche zeigen
dass in aller deutlichkeit und bei der
konjunktur entwicklung sind wir mit
höchster unsicherheit konfrontiert
wir sehen dass die
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute ihre
prognosen deutlich reduziert haben das
zww in mannheim zieht in seinem index
zur konjunkturerwartung in deutschland
den stärksten rückgang seit beginn der
umfrage im dezember 1991 der ifo
geschäftsklima index heute bricht ein
drei viertel der industriebetriebe
beklagen störungen in der lieferkette
und logistik 90 prozent fehlen rohstoffe
und vorleistungen in der tendenz sind
branchen betroffen die durch die
pandemie eher weniger belastet waren
insofern können bestehende instrumente
wie der steuerliche verlustvortrag gut
wirken auch das kurzarbeitergeld an
helfen arbeitslosigkeit zu vermeiden und
fachkräfte zu sichern es ist aber
möglich dass wir hier zusätzlich
unterstützung brauchen wir müssen uns
klar machen wir erleben einen
wohlstandsverlust wir werden als staat
nicht jede individuelle belastungen
ausgleichen können deshalb sind
zielgenaue belastungen entlastungen für
die bürgerinnen und bürger umso
wichtiger das gelingt grosso modo mit
dem entlastungspaket der ampel sehr gut
gerade die energie steuer pauschale ist
ein hervorragendes instrument die
pauschale muss gemäß der individuellen
leistungsfähigkeit versteuert werden der
finanzminister hat unterstrichen das
hilft der zielgenauigkeit der entlastung
auch die unterstützung für familien
kommt dort an wo sie gebraucht wird wer
die meine familie vom kinderfreibetrag
profitiert wird nicht entlastet ich
halte das für gerecht
die temporäre energie steuersenkung auf
kraftstoffe wird von vielen ökonomen und
ökonomen kritischer gesehen nicht
zielgenau und in der wirkung regressiv
ist die ziemlich einhellige einschätzung
da haben wir als ampel mit der
vereinbarten reform der unterstützung
für pendlerinnen und pendler noch
einiges zu tun und bessere instrumente
zu entwickeln
ich bin froh dass wir jetzt mit
hochdruck einen auszahlungsplan ismus
für das klima geld entwickeln wir dürfen
das morgen auch in dieser schwierigen
situation heute nicht aus dem blick
lassen nächstes jahr können wir dann
neue wege bei der zielgenauen entlastung
gehen wir dürfen die soziale frage nicht
gegen den klimaschutz ausspielen das
verbindet uns szenario
die andere regierung ist gute 100 tage
im amt auf unserem kontinent findet ein
furchtbarer angriffskrieg stadt wir
handeln als koalition in dieser für uns
alle so schweren zeit
verantwortungsbewusst das werden wir
auch bei den haushaltsberatungen in der
nächsten wochen zeigen herzlichen dank
die haushaltsberatung stehen natürlich
unter dem eindruck des ukraine kriegs
und auch der notwendigkeit darauf zu
reagieren
stand heute hat die bundespolizei
253.000 kriegsflüchtlinge in deutschland
festgestellt aber menschen aus polen
mitgenommen aus der ukraine brauchen
natürlich gerade kein wind dürfte die
wirkliche zahl sehr viel
karsten klein spricht jetzt für die fdp
fraktion
er ist obmann im haushaltsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
fortschritts koalition aus spd grünen
und fdp legen mit dem haushaltsentwurf
2022 den ersten schritt zur
modernisierung unseres landes vor wir
investieren in digitalisierung in
transformation in klimawandel und wir
tun das alles nach 16 jahren in denen
dieses land zunehmend verkrustet ist und
diese modernisierung umso wichtiger ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir werden aber in diesem haushaltsplan
auch noch erhebliche belastungen der
krise allein im geschäftsbereich des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums
26,3 milliarden euro unter
bundesfinanzminister wir tun dies alles
unter einhaltung der zuvor von der
großen koalition geplanten
neuverschuldung in höhe von 99,7
milliarden euro und ich will es an der
stelle noch mal sagen wir modernisieren
dieses land und getragen die belastungen
auf der korona krise unter schulden uns
nicht mehr als sie geplant hatten diese
außergewöhnlichen situation
am 24.2 hat vladimir putin den
verbrecherischen krieg über die ukraine
gebracht die antwort dieser
bundesregierung hat auf dem fuß erfolgt
100 milliarden euro sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr um versäumnisse vor allem
der vergangenheit auszufinanzieren der
bundesminister sie haben einen
ergänzungs haushalt angekündigt in dem
die verwerfungen belastungen aufgrund
dieses ukraine gries und der sanktionen
abgebildet werden sollen humanitäre
hilfe wirtschaftshilfen das
entlastungspaket hat die koalition
gestern schon auf den weg gebracht im
nächsten tagesordnungspunkt
werden wir über gasspeicher anlagen der
minister haarberg sprechen und deshalb
will ich hier nochmal klar für uns
formulieren nicht ständig spreche nicht
nur für die freien demokraten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wo soll denn
diese kritik der union begründet sein
dass wir nicht schnell und zupackend
handeln ich glaube wir setzen ein klares
zeichen in der woche dass wir sehr
handlungsfähig sind in extremer
krisensituation
und weil der in einen oder anderen rede
die dieser woche gehalten worden ist und
leider auch heute bei diesem
tagesordnungspunkt konnte man den
eindruck haben dass sich ja einige
kollegen und kolleginnen gerade so die
sich über neuverschuldung freuen die bei
jeder gelegenheit
ja die möglichkeit sehen dieser
bundesregierung neuverschuldung
vorzuwerfen und ich will an der stelle
noch einmal festhalten christian lindner
hatte schon erwähnt wir haben uns zur
schuldenbremse die im grundgesetz
verankert ist bekannt wir werden das
sondervermögen über eine
grundgesetzänderung verankern die kröten
die schuldenbremse im grundgesetz lässt
ausnahmesituationen zu und deshalb
werden wir ganz verfassungsgemäß auch in
zukunft die finanzpolitik aufsetzen das
ist solide dass dies vor allem aber das
ist vor allem aber seriöse finanzpolitik
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union und das haben wir reden heute hier
vermissen lassen und
deshalb liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
kommen
sie bitte zu sie sollten sich nicht über
neuverschuldung freuen sondern sollten
uns dabei unterstützen dass wir hier
seriöse haushaltspolitik fortsetzen wie
wir sie eingebracht haben vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege matthias sauer
für die cdu/csu
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren in europa tobt ein
fürchterlicher krieg und dazu sprach
präsident selensky vor wenigen tagen
hier im deutschen bundestag er sagte
herr bundeskanzler stolz reißen sie
diese mauer nieder geben sie deutschland
wie führung die es verdient oder auf die
ihre nachbarn oder stolz sein können
unterstützen sie uns unterstützen sie
den frieden unterstützen sie jeden
ukraine stoppen sie den krieg helfen sie
uns ihn zu stoppen
sagte imk rheinische präsident drei
wochen nach dem mut ihn den überfall auf
die gesamte ukraine befohlen hat mit
bonbons und panzern dem erdboden
gleichgemacht und städten mit millionen
vertriebenen und mit tausenden toten und
wir müssen uns fragen
tut deutschland wirklich genug um das
weitere morden durch die russische armee
in der ukraine zu verhindern präsident
selensky hat deutlich gesagt das ist
nicht der fall und auch ich glaube
deutschland mussten merten er
bundeskanzler sie und ihre regierung
sind in den ersten wochen der russischen
invasion der ihrer verantwortung nicht
gerecht geworden es reicht nicht nur
symbolisch an der seite der ukraine
zustehende solidarität bedeutet starke
hilfe und die muss jetzt eher egal ob
bei waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
beim aufsetzen von ostring 2 beim
ausschluss russischer banken aus dem
lift system oder auch bei anderen
sanktionen ihre regierung stand stets
auf der bremse es waren so partner die
die ukraine
nach kräften unterstützt haben die ampel
position war immer langsamer weniger
teilweise gar nicht und das während
putin die existenz eines ganzen landes
in europa versucht sie vernichten und es
erfolgte zu recht ein enormer druck auf
die ampel aus der deutschen
öffentlichkeit und auch von unseren
partnern aus europa und der ganzen welt
und bei ihrer regierungserklärung hat
bundeskanzler haben sie eine zeitenwende
angekündigt ich habe an diesem tag
wirklich gedacht die zeit des zauderns
und des zögerns ist jetzt vorbei mit
harten sanktionen gegen russland mit 2
prozent des bips für die bundeswehr mit
einem zusätzlichen 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr und
auch mit der lieferung von
verteidigungswaffen an die ukraine und
cdu und csu reichen ihnen die hand in
diesen zeiten von krieg und frieden eng
zusammenzuarbeiten aber nur wenn es
ihnen mit diesen ankündigungen auch
ernst ist und laut rudern sich jetzt
schon zurück als präsident saleh sie
herr bundeskanzler persönlich hier im
deutschen bundestag ansprache an sie
persönlich appellierte da schwiegen sie
sie gaben ihm keine antwort sie wollten
keine debatte und stattdessen wurden
geburtstagswünsche vorgelesen und es war
der bestellliste moment den ich in
diesem hohen hause
und was ist aus ihren ankündigungen
geworden die wenigen waffenlieferung
laufen schleppend liefern sie der
ukraine endlich die waffen die es den
tapferen ukraine ermöglicht putins armee
zu stoppen präsident sie lenski hat in
seiner rede vor dem deutschen bundestag
es lebe die ukraine gesagt damit er
seine rede abgeschlossen lassen sie uns
dazu beitragen dass die ukraine leben
kann und auch bei der bundeswehr bleibt
die ampel war im vorgelegten haushalt
wird das zwei prozent ziel eben nicht
erfüllt statt 75 milliarden 50
milliarden in einem mittelfristigen
finanzplanung fehlen jahr zu jahr 25
milliarden stattdessen soll es nun ein
sondervermögen mit grundgesetzänderung
lösen das wollen sie dazu nutzen weil
sie eben das 2% sie im regulären
haushalt gar nicht erreichen wollen und
zusätzlich stellen sie nun in frage ob
das geld überhaupt vollständig der
bundesrat zu gute kommen soll lassen sie
solche tricks unterstützen sie
geschlossen der bundeswehr dann haben
sie uns auch an ihrer seite
und bei der nächsten aufgabe sollen sie
sich ebenfalls wollen sie ebenfalls
keine zeit verlieren hunderttausende
menschen vor allem frauen und kinder
sind derzeit
aus der ukraine auf den weg nach
deutschland viele sind schon gekommen
der zustrom wird weiter zunehmen und
unser land leute diesen und menschen
schützen und er sollte sie mit offenen
armen empfangen wir dürfen die
unglaubliche hilfsbereitschaft erlebt
viele deutsche nehmen menschen bei sich
zu hause auf sie spenden sie
unterstützen
hilfsorganisationen kirchen private
initiativen viele ehrenamtler packen mit
an und diese solidarität ist
beeindruckend und sie ist wunderbar
auf staatlicher ebene sind es vor allem
unsere städte und gemeinden die jetzt
schon vor großen herausforderungen
stehen dort werden die menschen
untergebracht und versorgt dort die
beschulung der kinder sichergestellt und
dort stellen sich jetzt gerade viele
fragen wie werden die flüchtlinge nach
deutschland verteilt die antwort der
bundesregierung
fehlanzeige wer kommt für die
entstehenden kosten auf antwort
fehlanzeige wie schützen sie gerade
frauen und kinder vor ausbeutung und
menschenhandel antwort fehlanzeige und
wie sorgen sie für eine lückenlose
registrierung sie können sich denken an
ford fehlanzeige der bund muss bei
diesen fragen handeln und es hätte schon
längst frau bundesministerin caesar ist
jetzt gerade nicht da gerade war sie
noch da es hätte schon längst eine
flüchtlings kittel geben müssen gerade
auch unter beteiligung der länder und
kommunen
und abschließend
möchte ich eines klar sagen für den
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
russlands gibt es keinerlei
rechtfertigung
manche haben sich viel zu lange von blut
putin blenden lassen oder ihn sogar
unterstützt bei linksradikalen bei
rechtsradikalen weit verbreitet aber
teilweise sogar in demokratischen
parteien
dem traurigen
tiefpunkt bildet gerhard schröder
spd altkanzler als lobbyist für
russisches gas
und als oberster kriegsverbrecher
verstehe bezahlt haben deutschen
steuerzahler nein herr schröder dieser
krieg ist keine folge politischen
versagens das hat er noch gestern mit
blick auf den westen gesagt in diesem
krieg gibt es nur einen aggressor und
das ist putins russland und wir müssen
unseren teil dazu beitragen diese
aggression zu stoppen vielen dank für
die aufmerksamkeit
matthias brauer war das für die
unionsfraktion nächster redner ist
andreas schwartz er sitzt im bundes
finanzierungs gremium und in diesem
gremium werden die abgeordneten vom
bundesfinanzministerium über den umfang
der verschuldung des bundes unterrichtet
und üben da dann auch die kontrolle über
diese verschuldung aus
präsident liebe kolleginnen kollegen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
vor dem transit bildschirmen lassen sie
mich mit einem zitat von marie von
ebner-eschenbach beginnen die hat mal
gesagt
für das können gibt es nur einen beweis
dass tun sehr geehrte damen und herren
der vorgelegte bundeshaushalt beweist
die ampel tut und das in nicht wirklich
einfachen zeiten trotz vieler
herausforderungen das zahlenwerk ist ja
jetzt schon ein feuerwerk der guten
laune es garantiert den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt und
macht unser starkes land zukunftssicher
gerade in dieser zeit ist es daher
absolut bedeutsam zum einen stabilität
zu sichern aber auch zum anderen
handlungsfähigkeit zu zeigen
der bundeshaushalt
2022 tut dies obwohl die auswirkungen
des krieges in der und das möchte ich
mal kurz hinweis meine zeit
habt ihr anblick alles klar nicht dass
es heißt wir nehmen hier vorteilsnahme
im amt
der bundeshaushalt
2022 tut dies obwohl die auswirkungen
des krieges in der ukraine noch gar
keine berücksichtigung finden konnten
dazu wird in kürze ein ergänzungs
haushalt vorgelegt werden der dann
zusammengefügt wird mit dem
haushaltsentwurf der uns gerade vorliegt
der ein gesamtvolumen von 457 milliarden
euro hat die ampelkoalition ist getragen
von dem fortschritt gedanken das ist
eine große chance für unser land und ein
moderner und vor allen dingen
entschlossener geist trägt diesen willen
der veränderung wir werden viel geld in
die hand nehmen und das verkehrsnetz
modernisieren und das überwiegend in
china des weiteren werden wir die
digitalisierung sowie erhebliche
finanzielle mittel in bildung und
forschung unseres landes investieren
weil kinder und jugendliche sind unsere
zukunft und werte kolleginnen und
kollegen der klimaschutz ist zentrales
thema in diesem haushalt über 200
milliarden euro nehmen wir bis
2026 in die hand das hat es noch nie
gegeben warum machen wir das meine damen
und herren weil es gut ist und vor allen
dingen weil wir es können und aus der
verantwortung gegenüber nachfolgenden
generationen
bestehen somit vor riesigen
herausforderungen die digitalisierung
und transformation ist eine in eine
klimaneutrale wirtschaft ist eine solche
wir stehen vor einem schwierigen wandel
in den arbeitsprozessen und müssen
sorgen und ängste der menschen ernst
nehmen die menschen erwarten von uns
antworten die unternehmen
planungssicherheit
sie liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
sollen die gewinner dieses wandels sein
und wir wollen weiterhin eine starke
volks und exportwirtschaft bleiben daran
arbeitet diese ampel sehr geehrte damen
und herren das nämlich noch drei dinge
erwähnen mit diesem haushalt geben wir
sicherheit im wandel innere äußere und
soziale sicherheit sind dabei die maxime
im bereich der sozialen sicherheit sind
wir
oder haben wir bereits umfangreiche
entlastungs paket geschnürt ein
feuerwerk der guten ideen hat ja kevin
kühnert vorhin schon gerade gezündet und
gezeigt was wir da alles so im köcher
haben auch das ist ein klares signal wir
reden nicht nur von verantwortung
beleben diese und wir handeln nach
verantwortung und verantwortungsvoll zum
schluss lassen sie mich noch etwas zu
inneren äußeren sicherheit sagen thema
innere sicherheit hier spielt neben der
bundespolizei thw die blaulicht familie
vor allen dingen auch der zoll eine
wichtige rolle einnimmt mindestens die
hälfte der bundeseinnahmen ein für uns
und es würde mich freuen wenn wir den
weg weiter mutig gemeinsam gehen bei der
bekämpfung schwarzarbeit kontrolle
mindestlohn und bei der
geldwäschebekämpfung meine damen und
herren putins angriffskrieg hat die
gesamte welt lage verändert unsere
sicherheit ist im wandel eine
zeitenwende wir werden die ausstattung
der bundeswehr vor allen dingen aber die
ausrüstung unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten
schnellstmöglich mit dem 100 milliarden
sondervermögen modernisieren unsere
botschaft an die welt wir haben eine
wehrhafte demokratie
und wir sind ein zuverlässiger
bündnispartner sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich freue mich nun auf die vielen
verhandlungen gespräche neuen
erkenntnisse und einen wunderbaren
bundeshaushalt der uns den weg in die
zukunft zeigt dankeschön
[Applaus]
so während das pult vorbereitet wird
eine information an alle noch
nachfolgenden rednerinnen und redner der
kleine unfall vorhin hat hier
offensichtlich folgen aber wir sind
nicht nicht hilflos und werden uns auch
weiter entsprechend an die redezeiten
alten das heißt sie haben jetzt hier
wurm einen entsprechenden wecker können
auch den ablauf der redezeit verfolgen
sollte ihm das nicht gelingen werde ich
mich da ich habe mir gesagt auch dass
sie in alle hier im moment nicht
erleuchten kann äußern heißt ich hätte
jetzt tatsächlich den knopf gedrückt und
sie sollten den schlusspunkt sofort
besetzen
wir fahren fort in der schlussrunde zum
bundeshaushalt das wort hat der kollege
felix banaszak für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen
wenn sie denn schäden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen vielen dank für diesen
service und die pragmatische lösung herr
auer ich finde wir können dieser debatte
ja ganz unterschiedliche positionen
abwägen das ist alles schön und gut aber
das sind vertreter der unions fraktion
und der regierung tragenden fraktionen
der letzten jahre dieser regierung
zögern und zaudern bei 19 2 vorwirft das
ist schon ein stück der dreistigkeit ich
kann mich daran erinnern wie annalena
baerbock als kanzlerkandidaten mit ihrem
kanzlerkandidaten armin laschet im
letzten sommer diskutiert hat und er
erklärt hat warum man da jetzt mal nicht
so dramatisch drauf gucken könnte das
ich würde ihnen an dieser stelle einfach
empfehlen ein bisschen mehr demut
bisschen mehr demut dass er angemessen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben in dieser woche sehr viele wie
ich finde bemerkenswerte und büsche
reden gehört aus allen demokratischen
fraktionen von der linken bis in die
union reden die versucht haben der
dramatik der lage angemessen zu sein wie
abgewogen haben die lösung gesucht haben
viele gute reden und dann kam friedrich
merz
wenn man als unions
oppositionsführer die erste rede in der
generaldebatte in dieser aktuellen
dramatischen situation hat minuten zur
verfügung hat sich wenige andere und
kein wort über das leid in der ukraine
sagt kein wort über das leid der
menschen die aus der ukraine hier in
vielen kein wort über die vielen krisen
die wir ansonsten schon haben sondern
sich ausschließlich aus
parteipolitischer motivation mit der
bundes neuen sondervermögen beschäftigt
dann hat man seine verantwortung nicht
ernst genommen und ich kann da nur sagen
wenn sie so in der offensive agieren
dann bin ich froh dass die opposition
sind und nicht regieren meine damen und
herren es
ist ja nicht so und manche rede wirkte
so als würde die aktuelle
krisensituation die aktuelle krieg auf
einer ansonsten vollkommen heile welt
treffen als hätten wir ansonsten eitel
sonnenschein gehabt die krone apa
nächste nur das offensichtlichste krisen
moment der letzten jahre eine
ungebremste klimakrise krise der dio
biodiversität die krise der
multilateralen ordnung die krise der
demokratie
all das war doch vorher schon da und
angela merkel ab 2016 etwas richtiges
gesagt die welt ist aus den fugen nur
meine damen und herren sie haben daraus
nun die konsequenzen gezogen sie haben
weitergemacht als gäbe es kein morgen
und dieser bundeshaushalt ist der
haushalt der den hebel umlegt ist der
erste bundeshaushalt seit jahren der die
dramatik der situation überhaupt erstmal
reflektiert den die multiple das
multiple krisenszenario ernst nimmt und
die richtigen schlüsse die richtigen
prioritäten setzt darauf zu reagieren
meine
damen und herren ich mal der tiefpunkt
dieser woche das reden viel über die
sogenannte
feministische außen- sicherheits- und
entwicklungspolitik dass von der af dazu
nur quatsch kompass hat mich nicht
verwundert aber dass aus ihren reihen
dazu häme und spott kam und das abgetan
wurde als wäre das irgendwie gewöhnt und
das von einem oppositionsführer
friedrich merz dennoch 1997 gegen die
strafbarkeit der vergewaltigung in der
ehe gestimmt hat sie haben sich in den
letzten jahren so hinein radikalisiert
darin dass feminismus gender sternchen
heiß und ansonsten nicht und all die
dramatischen situation die anna lena
werbung beschrieben hat überhaupt nicht
überhaupt nicht respektiert und ich kann
ihnen nur den hinweis geben dass
sie damit im jahr 2022 keinen boden gut
machen werden ich habe mich in den
ersten wochen hier im deutschen
bundestag gefragt und habe eine
erfahrene kollegin gefragt waren wir
2005 als wenn die oppositions in die
opposition kamen auch so ahlmann und
werth gesagt wir hatten 2005 2008 2009
fiel krisen damit ihr staatstragende
reden gehalten die als opposition die
regierung des schnitts in der euro-krise
in der wirtschaftskrise 2008 und sie
haben diese woche nicht genutzt diese
form von oppositioneller verantwortung
zu zeigen
und deshalb
freut mich wenn sie die gelegenheit in
den nächsten wochen noch waren denen wir
werden als koalitionsfraktionen die
haushaltsberatungen nutzen einen guten
entwurf noch besser zu machen ich freue
mich auf ihre vorschläge wie wir das
noch besser hinbekommen können
[Applaus]
dafür bin ich 90 die grünen und auf ihn
folgt nun eine
koalitionspartnerin wie gestern ist
mitglied der spd fraktion sitzt im
haushaltsausschuss und auch im
rechnungsprüfungsausschuss dass dort wo
die abgeordneten die mittel bewilligen
die im haushalt eingesetzt werden soll
der vorsitzende meine damen und herren
wir
kamen immer wir haben den russischen
angriffskrieg wir stecken immer noch in
der korona pandemien wir haben die
globale klimakrise und damit befinden
wir uns in einem politischen
haushalterischen auch haushalterischen
ausnahmezustand und die frage die wir
doch heute am ende dieser ersten
haushaltswoche uns zu stellen haben ist
ob wir die antworten haben für diese
ausnahmezustände für den ausnahmezustand
und wenn ich mir die debatten der
letzten tage angucke dann komme ich zu
einem klaren ja wir haben die antwort
aber ich komme auch zu der einschätzung
dass große teile der oppositionsfraktion
noch nicht so ganz verstanden haben was
wir machen und darum weil ich vor in der
pädagogischen psychologie gearbeitet
habe es gibt eine opposition
da sage ich auch ganz ehrlich habe ich
gar nicht mehr die erwartungen aber die
reden die insbesondere die
unionsfraktion heute hier aber auch im
laufe der ganzen woche gemacht haben die
bringen doch zumindest danke für die
zweite ersatz uhr die bringen man noch
den eindruck dass es noch gar nicht ganz
verstanden wurde wir reagieren auf die
haushalts als haushälter binnen und
haushälter auf die ausnahmezustände
erstes mit einem ergänzungs haushalt in
dem werden wir die unmittelbaren kosten
aus der krise aus dem krieg der ukraine
abbilden da geht es um humanitäre hilfe
da geht es um die wirtschaftshilfen da
geht es um entlastungspaket und da geht
es um die kosten für die geflüchteten
die wir untergebracht haben und der
kollege kevin kühnert hat es alles schon
auf gezahlt gezählt wir haben ein
umfassendes maßnahmenpaket mit
energiepreis pauschale mit kinderbonus
mit pnv flatrate für neun euro im monat
in dieser woche beschlossen und wir
haben davor im umfang von auch nochmal
15 milliarden euro in den wochen zuvor
auch schon die menschen und lässt das
heißt wir sind gut unterwegs was die
themen der entlastung angeht wir werden
jetzt im ergänzungs haushalten noch im
april darüber sprechen was weitere
kosten angeht wir haben zweitens das
sondervermögen damit reagieren wir auf
die schlechte ausstattung der bundeswehr
der letzten jahre der unions geführten
verteidigungsministerium und das
sondervermögen der reichsten
obendrauf
wir werden drittens meine damen und
herren den klima und
transformationsprojekte um darauf zu
reagieren dass wir eine weltweite klima
krise haben und wir werden vier den
kernhaushalt im umfang von über 450
milliarden euro beraten
und wir werden inhaltlich bei alldem
ganz klar haben innere äußere und
soziale sicherheit für gehören bei uns
zusammen das ist der sicherheit im
wandel den wir bieten und das ist die
sicherheit im wandel den wir den
menschen schuldig sind
und wir sind zwei sachen auch wichtig
das eine ist dass wir ja mehr schulden
machen für das sondervermögen der
bundeswehr in ausnahmesituationen müssen
wir auch außergewöhnliche maßnahmen
ergreifen
langfristig werden wir aber genauso mit
hochdruck daran arbeiten internationale
verträge und eine friedensordnung zu
bekommen die friedenspolitik ist für uns
gleichermaßen wichtig die brauchen wir
auch um die hohe akzeptanz die das
sondervermögen aktuell in der
bevölkerung hat aufrechtzuerhalten und
darum werden wir uns darum kümmern und
meine damen und herren
abschließend die wichtigste währung die
wir als politikerinnen und politiker
haben ist das vertrauen der menschen und
dieses vertrauen sollten wir
insbesondere dann sehr sorgsam
betrachten wenn es darum geht wie wir
die gelder verwenden die die menschen
erbracht haben mit dem steuern diese
gezahlt haben und darum bin ich sicher
dass wir in den nächsten wochen
sorgfältig intensiv und konstruktiv in
der ampel koalition über diese vier
haushaltsposten und ob diese vier
haushalte und die einzelpläne beraten
werden darauf freue ich mich dass wir
auf konstruktive opposition verzichten
müssen das hat die woche leider auch
gezeigt aber wir stellen dann eben
unsere mehrheiten werben koalition
herzlichen dank
siebtbester war das mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss ist natürlich der
haushaltsausschuss der die mittel
bewilligt ein mächtiger ausschuss von
dem so wird gesagt der sich auch dass
man bewusst ist dass er diese machte hat
und das auch gerne mal ein minister oder
ein so stört
engelbert größte spielt jetzt für die
unionsfraktion letzte rednerin in dieser
schluss vorne zu hause
kollegen ich möchte auch die damen und
herren minister begrüßen ich finde es
beachtlich dass sie hier sind 10 35
stunden miteinander den haushaltsentwurf
debattiert und herr kollege fricke ist
der haushaltsentwurf der regierung und
nicht der der opposition
35 stunden lassen wir hier oben gefährt
zusammen und ich muss ihnen sagen ich
bin dass meine erste haushaltsberatung
deutschen bundestag aber ich habe schon
ein paar jahre im landtag verbracht und
ich habe 15 jahre im europaparlament
verbracht bei ihr müsst ihr was ändern
ihr müsst anders miteinander umgehen das
kann so nicht bleiben ich bin überrascht
über die plattitüden und die belehrungen
die ganz junge leute die hier ganz ganz
ganz unerfahren sind den anderen geben
warum tut er das wir benehmt euch ihr
benehmt euch als hättet ihr das rad das
rad an der schießbude gleichzeitig
erfunden und ich möchte und im zweifel
muss dann eigentlich
eine schuldzuweisung herhalten und das
ist dann eine haushaltsberatung ich
möchte schon noch mal darauf
zurückkommen was wir was eigentlich der
kern der kritik der union ist der kern
der kritik der union ist dass wir einen
haushaltsentwurf beraten in dem alles
falsch ist die zahlen sind falsch die
einnahmen sind falsch die ausgaben sind
falsch und sie beschäftigen uns damit
dass das doch so sein muss ich kann
ihnen sagen nein es muss nicht sein das
europäische parlament hätte der
kommission einstimmig über alle
parteigrenzen hinweg diesen
haushaltsentwurf zurückgegeben so doch
nicht unsere kritik besteht doch darin
dass wir gerne einen haushaltsentwurf
hätten mit dem wir wirklich arbeiten
können dann sagte frau kollegin hagedorn
pumpt noch konnten ja prima kommt noch
aber wir wollen einfach die dinge auch
beurteilen können wir möchten übrigens
auch gut behandelt werden und jetzt
nämlich mal gestern gestern hat der herr
finanzminister vordertür eine
pressekonferenz gegeben und hat dort
erklärt ein paket mit entlastungen hier
nicht wir haben hier zusammen gesessen
und hier wurde davon nicht gesprochen
der einzige der ein bisschen was
angedeutet hat und dafür bin ich dankbar
war der landwirtschaftsminister ich habe
immer diese 35 stunden wirklich angetan
aber so kann man doch nicht miteinander
umgehen mit uns nicht aber mit ihnen
doch auch nicht was lassen sie sich
alles von ihren eigenen leuten gefallen
das ist ja beängstigend es besorgt es
besorgt mich dass man mit gegen
offensichtlich alles machen kann und
herr kollege kinder mit denen worum es
machen kann sage ich ihn aus
langjähriger erfahrung mit regierungen
mit den macht man es auch warum bestehen
sie nicht darauf dass sie anständig
behandelt werden das hat den angenehmen
nebeneffekt dass wir vielleicht auch
besser behandelt werden ich möchte schon
noch sagen was wir eigentlich zum thema
schuldenbremse hier eigentlich gesehen
haben die ganze woche über hat beim
thema schuldenbremse herr finanzminister
nur die fdp geklatscht im rennen aber
nur mit der fdp warten sie es nicht
hinkriegen das heißt das ist doch wir
haben so vieles sollbruchstellen in
diesem haus gesehen und wir fürchten
natürlich auch das sieht der
finanzminister sein werden der die
größte neuverschuldung aber in diesem
haus zu präsentieren hat und genau auf
dem weg sind wir inzwischen und warum
sind wir auf dem weg weil der
haushaltsentwurf natürlich mitnichten
konsolidiert ist weil der
haushaltsentwurf überhaupt keine
einsparungen vorsieht überhaupt keine
kann kein besseres mit keine bessere
mittelverwendung aber ohne die geht es
nicht und dann zu sagen jetzt müsst ihr
aber um einen vorschlag machen halte ich
also vor ziemlich ziemlich gewagt diese
woche
diese woche war interessant
wir haben in dieser woche die
rückführung der ampel erlebt um
schmetterlinge zur raupe und ich muß ich
kann verstehen dass man damit fertig
werden muss ich ganz so stehen aber so
kann es doch nicht gehen dass wir hier
sind in selbstmitleid und in
schockstarre
versuchen eine woche eine woche hinter
uns zu bringen
die eigentlich dazu da ist dass wir
miteinander und gemeinsam lösungen
finden wir haben wir haben das faktum
dass die koalition in wesentlichen
fragen keine mehrheit hat und das ist
der elefant im raum um den es geht die
fehlenden mehrheiten deswegen haben wir
den bundeswehr vor deswegen haben wir
das infektionsschutzgesetz und deswegen
haben wir auch genau die probleme mit
denen wir uns beschäftigen müssen wir
haben ein infektionsschutzgesetz das
unter seinen möglichkeiten bleibt und
deswegen haben hohe incident deswegen
geht die korona pandemie weiter wir
haben statt eine entideologisierung bei
der energiewende haben wir eine
ideologisierte energiewende mit dem
problem dass wir dann eben deutschland
nichts sicher durch den nächsten winter
bringen können und die angemessene
unterstützung der ukraine
hätten
ich verstehe ja dass es schwierig ist
weil da muss müssen viele bürger
schatten springen aber eine angemessene
unterstützung der ukraine hätte sie und
uns von der verantwortung vor der
geschichte entlastet und sie werden
sehen die leser wird sein wir haben den
fehler gemacht aggression erst möglich
gemacht zu haben und vor diesem diktum
der geschichte fürchte ich mich ich
möchte dass wir auf jeden fall die alten
fehler doch nicht noch einmal machen ja
das ist das tut weh und stehst worüber
ich an gesprächen möchte ist dass wir
neue planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
brauchen wir müssen dinge verändern in
diesem land und da haben sie uns auf
ihrer seite erneuerbare energien
ausbauen unbedingt aber dazu gehört
natürlich auch der netzausbau ich weiß
aber wirtschaftsminister sie sind dran
mehr windmühlen ist nicht das einzige
problem wir haben letztes jahr eine
milliarde euro an windkraftbetreiber
gezahlt damit sie die wirkungen
abschalten ich meine was nützt es dann
wenn wir mehr windmühlen ausstellen wir
müssen die probleme lösen wo sie sind
und da muss ich sagen hat den unter
komplexe problemanalyse die ich heute
die ich gehört habe in all diesen tagen
hat auch nicht geholfen ich habe es
gestern gesagt wir haben in schwäbisch
gmünd versuchen wir eine
wasserstofftankstelle zu machen müssen
vereine eine regelung umsetzen wie sie
von großanlagen geplant ist das ist
bitter weil vereine ist es ein großer
ein großer aufwand andere länder sind da
besser es wäre gut wenn wir hier einen
regulatorisch hätten die den projekten
angemessen ist und auch und auch den
einer schnellen umsetzung der
energiewende angemessen ist ich möchte
schon sagen dass wir mit dem paket
gesehen haben dass dinge möglich sind
die am dienstag noch für unmöglich
erklärt worden zum beispiel entlastung
an der zapfsäule ich finde es gut dass
menschen entlastet werden an der
zapfsäule aber auch finanzminister die
entlastung über die steuern und die
lohnsteuer ist schon ein bisschen gewagt
ziemlich pfiffig weil die hälfte bleibt
er dann auch gleich mal hin ich möchte
sagen ja ich weiß nicht auf der us tour
leuchtet das sie schon tatsächlich über
die redezeit sind
entschuldigen sie bitte entschuldigen
sie wirklich insgesamt ich möchte ihnen
sagen dass wir im haushaltsausschuss
ihnen helfen werden aber sie müssen auch
dafür sorgen dass man ihnen helfen kann
dankeschön
ingeborg gräßle war das um damit kommen
wir zum letzten redner in diesem
schlussgang an
die
möglicherweise wieder auch anwesenden
besucher auch all diejenigen die uns
zuhören und zusehen wir sind in der
schlussrunde zu den haushaltsberatungen
zum haushalt
2022 welche von dienstagmorgen bis jetzt
andauern und der voraussichtlich letzte
redner in dieser haushaltsdebatte ist
nun der kollege dennis oder für die spd
vielen dank frau präsidentin zunächst im
wissen um die besondere amt
verantwortung meiner fraktion sage ich
ihnen als berichterstatter für den
einzelplan 02 deutsche bundestag die
volle unterstützung bei den
haushaltsverhandlungen zur reparatur
dieses rednerpult ist
und war die erste vormerken
die zweite vorgemerkten frau kollegin
gräßle und das in aller deutlichkeit
leid ich glaube die vielen jungen
engagierten kolleginnen und kollegen
hier im haus brauchen wahrlich keine
moralpredigt kunden
wir sind am ende der ersten lesung
dieses auto ist auch noch jungandreas am
ende der ersten lesung dieses haushaltes
er geht jetzt in den haushaltsausschuss
und wir werden dann sehr lacht sachlich
darüber zu debattieren haben was uns
vorliegt aber ich finde das eine oder
andere muss man hier auch nochmal ein
ohne stand es schon bemerkenswert wie
immer wieder in den letzten tagen der
vorwurf der rekordverschuldung gerade
seitens der union richtung ampel kam der
haushalt der uns vorliegt sieht eine
verschuldung von 99,7 milliarden euro
vor der entwurf den wir 2020 beschlossen
haben im zweiten nachtrag zwischen cdu
csu und spd sei eine neuverschuldung von
217 8 milliarden euro vor der haushalts
20 21 im zweiten nachtrag verabschiedet
von cdu csu und spd sei eine
neuverschuldung von 200 40,2 milliarden
euro vor jeweils doppelt so viel als
dass worüber wir heute reden und sie
machen uns das zum vorbild will ihn aber
was sagen die
neuverschuldung damals wie heute war
richtig denn es ist unsere antwort auf
die knie die über unser land kommt es
ist ja
es ist ja nicht so dass wir damit
irgendwas finanzieren würden wir
finanzieren damit den arbeit den erhalt
der arbeitsplätze in deutschland wir
finanzieren damit den erhalt der
wirtschaftskraft in deutschland das war
2020 richtig dass 20 21 richtig und mit
verlaub dass es auch 2022 richtig liebe
kollegen abgegeben
denn die krisen sind ja nicht vorbei es
sind zusätzliche dazu gekommen und ich
glaube es gab keine rede ich hier im
haus die in den letzten tagen nicht den
russischen angriffskrieg thematisiert
hat nicht darüber gesprochen hat dass
wir eine neue sicherheitslage in europa
haben und natürlich muss die antwort
dann auch sein dass wir uns mit dem
auseinandersetzen was in deutschland
fehlt und was der bundeswehr fehlt und
ja der bundeskanzler hat angekündigt
dass ausstattungs defizit der bundeswehr
beheben zu wollen und ich will das auch
deutlich sagen ich habe das bei einem
dom und mit verwunderung aufgenommen der
dann nur von schulden gesprochen hat ja
das sind 100 milliarden euro die wir aus
schulden finanzieren müssen aber was ist
eigentlich die alternative wollen wir
mitten in dieser situation und nicht
wehrhaft machen als bundesrepublik
deutschland ich finde wir müssen uns
wehrhaft machen übrigens um uns niemals
zur wehr setzen zu müssen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und deswegen
und das ding ganz deutlich in ihre
richtung man kann jetzt wenn es um diese
100 milliarden paket geht ganz viel
parteitaktische parteipolitische spielte
man das kommt in der eigenen babbel
richtig gut an aber die menschen in
meinem wahlkreis nicht bin mit sicher
auch in ihren wahlkreisen die haben
angst die sorgen sich die sorgen sich
darum ob der konflikt der ukraine auch
hier zu uns rüberschwappt die sorgen uns
da und sie sollen sich darüber ob wir
vorbereitet sind die stellen sich die
frage ob sie morgen noch die energie
preise bezahlen können und ich finde sie
erwarten zu recht eine antwort der
politikerinnen und politiker im
deutschen bundestag und sie sind teil
des deutschen bundestages und soll nicht
alles nur für parteitaktik nutzen
und es geht hier nicht nur um die runden
milliarden-gewinn kühner hat das am
anfang angesprochen es geht auch um die
60 milliarden für den energie und
klimafonds
natürlich können sie klagen natürlich
können sie nach karlsruhe gehen wir sind
überzeugt die klage wirklich erfolgreich
sein aber was haben sie eigentlich
gewonnen wenn die klage erfolgreich ist
dann fehlen in diesem land 60 milliarden
euro die für die energieunabhängigkeit
gewinn nötig werden die dazu sind
möglich werden
russland zu werden wie wir energie
effizient für nötig ist das eigentlich
die botschaft die sie in dieses land aus
senden wollen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ist das eigentlich die
botschaft die sie senden wollen wir
wollen das nicht wir stellen uns unserer
verantwortung und ich habe auch diesen
einen satz in den letzten tagen immer
wieder von ihnen gehört schulden seien
die steuern von morgen
ich will das deutlich machen was
passiert dann wenn wir nichts machen die
investitionen die wir heute tätigen sind
vielmehr die steuereinnahmen von morgen
für die müssen wir heute zur politik
fahren und darum geht es die kolleginnen
und kollegen
deswegen ich weiß dass haushälterinnen
und haushälter wenn es dann in die
verhandlungen gehen sachlich
zusammenarbeit ich weiß dass vieles was
hier gesagt wurde nur diese mikrofon
geschuldet war ich bin mir sehr sicher
dass am ende alle zu ihrer verantwortung
stehen und dass wir erkennen dass wir
was für die bundeswehr tun müssen und es
am ende auch tun ich glaube ich bin
sicher dass alle ihre verantwortung
erkennen dass hier was machen müssen um
energie unabhängig zu werden und dass
sie am ende auch alle ihren beitrag dazu
leisten werden darum geht es in den
nächsten wochen wir müssen den menschen
in diesem land sicherheit in dieser zeit
im wandel geben darum geht es dafür
setzen wir uns ein und dafür bitte ich
sie alle um ihre mitarbeit vielen dank
ich schließe die aussprache
interfraktionell blut überweisung der
vorlagen auf den druck 26
31.500 1 an den haushaltsausschuss
vorgeschlagen so dass wir also jetzt die
schlussrunde